[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you know take the time show it's my
favorite show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
all right welcome everybody we are live
and it is a big big day hopefully a day
where we actually know the results today
before before the end of the night which
would be very different than what took
place last Monday welcome it is the day
of the New Hampshire Democratic and
Republican primaries really nothing to
talk about when it comes to the
Republican primary Donald Trump is going
to win we do have some very early
results that are essentially meaningless
so far although I actually do think
there is something important here there
was I think it's like one or two towns
that vote at midnight there's all these
traditions with a lot of this stuff
anyway Amy Klobuchar has eight votes now
this is not this is not Delegates right
this is literally eight people voted for
Amy Klobuchar four for Bernie four for
war and these are numbers from from last
night
most just updated about a half hour ago
and we are waiting now on the first
results CNN I am told is starting to
report some stuff so we will get over
there momentarily but we are going to
hopefully so there's two ways this would
this would go last year sorry last
primary at 8:00 p.m. Eastern Time
it was called for Bernie Sanders if I
recall correctly because it was so
overwhelming if we look at the 2016
results Bernie won a 60% to Hillary
Clinton's 37 percent shockingly a lot of
people don't know this but star lock did
get 33 votes in the 2016 New Hampshire
Democratic primary but Bernie Sanders
winning by so much now one of the things
you have to remember is they are going
to say look at how much of a decrease
Bernie Sanders got in terms of the share
of the vote and of course you have five
people polling over ten percent right
now so that is to be expected that's not
a particularly relevant change or
anything like that so we we are going to
be here I don't know how long if we do
get final results at 8:00 p.m. I will
still be here we will then start doing
delegate totals we will look at exit
polls we will look at up
coming up primaries we may open up the
phone lines we may do all sorts of
different things in the meantime as we
await results at the top of the hour I
will answer questions via super chat on
YouTube as well as via a subscription
messages twitch Prime and regular
subscriptions over on Twitch welcome if
you're watching on YouTube welcome if
you're watching on Twitch and then of
course welcome if you are watching on
Facebook as well quick note as alluring
Lord says with their twitch Prime
subscription good job on the ROG Royale
did you have fun actually hold let me
look at our subscription images working
they are ok very good
yes I was on a program called the ROG
Royale over the weekend and incredibly I
actually won and I defeated a gentleman
who goes by the name airsoft fatty and
airsoft fatty is not a gentleman I was
familiar with prior to defeating him in
the final of the ROG Royale over the
weekend but I have to tell you I've been
watching some of this gentleman airsoft
fatties youtube content he is one of the
greatest entertainers of our time one of
the greatest contemporary entertainers I
highly encourage people to check out
airsoft fatties Channel this is the name
this gentleman has chosen for himself
it's not my name and maybe later we will
play the the final moments let's just
listen to a few seconds now are you
clear ok what what sort of things do you
find a problem with people being
sensitive about so as you can see
everything going wrong during the grand
finale and in any case we will we will
get to that maybe maybe a little bit
later but truly one of the greatest
contemporary entertainers of our time I
dare say airsoft fatty definitely make
sure to check out the YouTube channel ok
let's see what we've got here
super shots are star
to trickle in the first one from tuba
who says simply burn baby burn Bernie
Sanders of course expected to do quite
well tonight let's take a look if we can
at the polling going in which I actually
now don't have handy but I will get just
momentarily for you we already looked at
the 2016 results let's take a look at
the New Hampshire numbers going in as
you can see looking at New Hampshire
Bernie Sanders the blue line with a big
surge over the last Oh of two to three
weeks or so you see Pete Budaj edge
peeking a few days ago and then losing a
bit and then I believe the surprise this
evening I believe the person who will do
the most above and beyond where they are
polling is Amy Klobuchar at rising to
eleven point seven percent today I
believe globish are will over perform
today I believe Biden may well end up
underperforming and that that's my
prediction I would love to see in the
chat what people think might be the most
surprising result but I do believe whoa
a lot of things happening here I do
believe that Amy is going to be going to
perform disproportionately well I don't
know that it will be shocking but I
think it will be a disproportionately
good performance let me say thank you to
Sir know thyself for subscribing with
twitch prime also her to Robbo 0-8 who
says thank you for your good work David
make America great again without Trump
and with Bernie greetings from Berlin
there is a hype train going on twitch
let's see what we can do with that let's
answer some super chats over on Twitch
AC zero five ten great to see you AC
quick question so how much would it cost
for you to live with Wes I heard he's
good content
yeah wit so that's very very inside
baseball so let's I will talk about that
maybe if we open up the phone lines
parity ran well compare from Sweden oh
man another long night well it doesn't
matter a winter in Sweden is always dark
but Bernie shines bright Thank You Pere
appreciate that
Ricky Williams also chiming in with a
beautifully timed super chat Ricky says
how many coffee cans would clover stars
grandpa need to save enough spare change
for college today oh you would need more
than just a few coffee cans yeah that
wouldn't even do it Ross Ecch bold says
how can I tell who is a Russian troll on
Twitter good question I don't look at
replies anymore and that's that's the
best way I just I couldn't tell so I got
right off of there Dustin DPS says if
Klobuchar was Budaj edge she'd already
declared victory with her dozens of
votes yes indeed we have new numbers
ladies and gentlemen Bernie Sanders
taking an early lead jumping to 38.2%
38.2% amy klobuchar now remember I said
just five minutes ago that Amy Klobuchar
will be the surprise of the night I
believe she will most drastically
overperform the polling Amy Klobuchar
now in second place ahead of former
South Bend mayor Pete Budaj edges 20.5%
this is with Jesus look at all these
candidates what percentage is this this
is with five of 301 precincts reporting
this is about roughly 1.5 percent of
precincts reporting Bernie Sanders out
to an early lead ahead of Amy Klobuchar
Pete Budaj edge Elizabeth Warren Biden
in fifth and if Biden finishes fifth
Biden has left the state by the way I
don't know if people know that but Biden
left and he's leaving his sister to do
this speech at his New Hampshire
headquarters and we see Tom Steyer and
Tulsi Andrew yang even Deval Patrick
getting 9 votes today and now Pete Budaj
edge surpassing Amy Klobuchar that could
be a fight but Bernie Sanders still in
the lead remember Bernie Sanders winning
easily almost by a two-to-one margin
over Hillary back in 2016 so we have
numbers and things are things are
getting going let me say thanks dude our
beacon for the twitch prime
sub spice goat for the twitch
subscription very much appreciate that
over on oh I do want to mention so we
have a different we have a great coupon
code today the coupon code for this
evening is 20 20 now why because it's 20
20 now no secrets about the coupon code
our target is 50 website members why 51
for each of the 50 United States the
United States states I guess we would
say everybody who signs up at join
pakman.com we'll start to fill up this
blue bar when the bar gets to the top as
Andrew yang picks up a few votes when
the bar gets to the top of course
everybody gets thanked but crazy things
happen when the bar fills completely
untold and ungodly things we are
starting to see numbers come in and so
far we are seeing a the biggest split
between Bernie and Pete of the evening
at about 12 points Pete and Amy
Klobuchar about three points apart and
then six points separating Amy Klobuchar
and Elizabeth Warren remember my
prediction was that Amy Klobuchar would
be the biggest / performer of the day as
you can see here Amy Klobuchar coming in
at eleven point seven percent and at
least as of right now with 17.5
over-performing the polls by about six
percentage points let me say thank you
to Zack Miller why zack well because he
has just signed up at joined pakman.com
and his new member number one out of 50
this evening really appreciate it AK I
really do let's see what is happening
over in Super chats Austin Clark says
Bernie's number one donor career is
teacher I am one as much as I love the
promised wage increases the systemic
change he brings is desperately needed
Ryan nawicki says your thoughts on DNC
super-delegates rule change so Ryan if
if the cnc has opted ruled to put the
super-delegates back in on round 1 i've
not heard about it yet so if someone can
let me know if that
happened I would appreciate that as far
as I know the DNC is considering giving
super-delegates the right to vote in the
first round at the DNC which would of
course be a way to deny Bernie the
nomination but if they've actually
changed the rule I've not heard of that
yet so let me know if that's the case
Charlie says god bless the United States
yes much the powerful words you know FDR
saying we have nothing to fear but fear
itself John F Kennedy said we do things
not because they are easy but because
they are hard and a great philosopher
Donald Trump of course known for God
bless the United Sates and wanting to
know the oranges the oranges of the
investigation thank you very much Ethan
Hendricks hey David I want to thank you
for your comments on Bolivia my
girlfriend is Bolivian and she was
saying the same things you were but feel
the Bern oh boy Ethan you might get me
cancelled by bringing up Bolivia again I
don't want that Zachary Monroe welcome
back Zack says it's going to be
disasterous
if Trump jr. tries for office in 2046 as
a political science major I need to beat
him to office thanks for the show DP D
Smitty says David would you do a charity
boxing match with ben shapiro purely in
good sport for a charity of the winners
choosing i would do it with an with a 30
ounce glove that that would be my
precondition for boxing boxing Ben
Shapiro if you were just joining us we
have so far let's actually look at the
delegate totals where I had the delegate
totals somewhere here here we go
going into this evening Pete Buddha edge
with 13 delegates of course the number
needed to secure the nomination as 1990
Bernie Sanders with 12 Warren eight
Biden six and Amy Klobuchar won I
believe that we may well see a
reorganization of those numbers after
today's primary we currently have Bernie
Sanders in first place with a as of yet
Cigna as of
of now significant lead over Pete Budaj
edge of 12 points with Amy Klobuchar
in third Elizabeth Warren in fourth and
Biden in a distant fifth if you combine
the progressives Bernie and Warren
currently they have forty three point
five percent of the vote nearly half the
vote going to the progressive candidates
today very interesting data to follow
and to track and we will of course be
doing it sheev Palpatine and I want to
hear from you I will go over to twitch
messages momentarily but I will continue
reading a few more Super chats sheev
Palpatine says I am the Senate Palpatine
2020 very good I don't understand that
but I appreciate the support I also
appreciate the super chat from Europe
from Katya Anna Calabro and clockwork
pineapple says Bernie Sanders son was a
Russian burlesque dancer if that's true
I am not aware of it let me say thanks
over on twitch to deejay gibster
who says will you be my Valentine David
sure why not space Panda says keep up
the good work David along with a
subscription a wild man appears has
subscribed with prime and sand monster
has subscribed with prime thank you very
much I appreciate that I also want to
say thanks to let me see if I can
pronounce this last name correctly Jan
short burger short beggar short beggar
who is a website member number two of
the evening we've got a coupon code it
saves you 66% and it is 2020 now the
info is there all of these memberships
are at join pakman.com we have just
boosted the power of the david pakman
show website because so many people
tried to sign up last livestream that
the website crashed and then I started
crying live on stream so hopefully it
will be able to handle another 48 people
signing up which is of course the the
goal today we continue to see the votes
Rowland as of two minutes ago Bernie
Sanders still holding a lead in
tonight's New Hampshire primary and a
slight adjustment there which has pulled
Pete Budaj edge about a point closer to
Bernie Bernie's lead now only eight
point seven over Pete Amy Klobuchar
drastically Rick Berman I am going to
restate my prediction here just so
everybody remembers I believe that
relative to the polling we are going to
see Amy over perform the polls by the
largest amount so for example Bernie was
polling can I assume that woody can we
get a zoom on this please there we go
Bernie was polling 28.7 going in and as
of right now is @ 30.4 meaning he's
polling about 1.7 ahead he polled he's
actually the results have him 1.7 ahead
of where he pulled Pete Budaj edge was
at 21 three and is right now at 21 seven
Amy Klobuchar pulled 11 7 and currently
is at 18 5 which has her six point eight
ahead of where she pulled I believe Clos
Bashar will be the biggest / performer
of the of the day JH WH Goodell says via
super chat is American exceptionalism
holding the u.s. back I uh I'd have to
think about that I'm not prepared to
deliver an answer there on a ket Patil
says do you think Bloomberg will end up
like Biden whereas polling is very high
but he ends up getting fewer votes than
expected given the facts fact he just
bought his way and I believe that
Bloomberg may end up third or fourth and
delegates by the time it's all said and
done I was looking today if you look at
Bloomberg Bloomberg in Florida and Texas
already has enough support to be both
viable over 15% and to pick up a bunch
of Delegates I think Bloomberg is going
to do much better than a lot of people
are predicting and I've been saying it
for weeks at this point let me welcome
Loren Parfitt Laura
Parfitt is new member number three at
join pakman.com the most direct way to
support these streams which we've been
doing State of the Union Iowa results
new hampshire results impeachment
hearings impeachment vote all this stuff
the best way to do it is by grabbing a
membership at join pakman.com and you
can do it at 66% off incredibly using
that code right up there let me say
thank you to ran Kasich na for
subscribing with twitch prime i
appreciate that other super chats that
are coming in if you have questions they
will pop up on the screen on the bottom
left of the screen if you send a super
chat on youtube they'll pop up in that
vertical blue rectangle above my head if
you send them via twitch subscription
Betazoid says during the intro song for
your show who is the voice saying the
david pakman show at david pakman.com oh
that's my old friend actually you know
what I shouldn't say his name because
he's actually a pretty well-known radio
voiceover artist it's an old friend of
mine who does a lot of radio radio
voiceovers who cut those lines for me
for free but unfortunately I have to
protect him he's actually a right winger
and that's not a joke
he just did me a favor so I'm gonna keep
his identity secret Scott Taylor Davis
do you have any drop out predictions
after tonight that's interesting drop
out uh I mean listen there's people who
obviously should have dropped out a long
time ago who haven't and the fact that
they haven't so far suggests maybe
they'll stay in but it seems to me that
Tulsi can probably end it after tonight
deval Patrick maybe will justify staying
in because Massachusetts is still to
vote and he was of course the governor
here in Massachusetts so maybe there's a
you know justification for for him to
stay and but I don't know it's it's hard
hard for me to say
Dease or listen I'm sorry I skipped
somebody absurd infection says burn one
for Bernie this states in the bag it is
very very possible that Bernie Sanders
will indeed win tonight D Smitty 1576
would you have
to a grand theft auto 5 livestream I
remember you saying you enjoy the series
yeah I don't I have not actually played
GTA 5 but I certainly consider that make
it simple says feel the burn kwb says
how would you rank the more centrist
candidates still in the race
Biden Budaj edge Klobuchar that's
interesting I'd have to think about that
other than his horrible racism and
history of stop and frisk I almost think
Bloomberg is more interesting than these
three centrists if you make me pick a
centrist although the Bendix and racism
revelations the audio from today is
absolutely stunning but I'd have to
think of it it never occurred to me to
support any of them
so I'm actually have not given it that
much thought sky our wby says have you
seen the what if Bernie Sanders had an
anime opening therefore good for a laugh
I have not seen it but I will make a
note of that
Erin Hamrick says it burns when I pee
tape Ave Sanders clearly speaking in
some code that I am not privy to and
Matthew Plumlee has also picked up a
YouTube subscription I appreciate that
over on Twitch I want to say thanks to
Farmer Kip for cheering five bits we now
have 5% reporting in New Hampshire
Bernie Sanders is in the lead with
nearly 30 percent of the vote
Pete Budaj edged in second place at 22
Amy Klobuchar at 18 and Warren at 12
Joseph R Biden Jr ladies and gentlemen
doing apparently the right thing in
getting the you-know-what out of New
Hampshire he's already landed in South
Carolina I think Joe Biden is polling so
far at 7.2 in the actual results
remember that Biden was polling 11 on
the way in so I I believe that not only
will Amy Klobuchar likely be the biggest
/ performer of the night Biden may end
up being the largest under performer of
the night relative to the polling going
in which is absolutely incredible and
Sajjad
it's a possible rapid implosion quite
frankly of Joe Biden's campaign for
president let me say thank you and
welcome to Joshua Dietz Joshua is new
member number four at join pakman.com I
also want to say thank you to Jacob
Hendricks who is new member number five
at join pakman.com tanner
captain igloo is new member number six
at join pakman.com strikes me as
potentially a that a Turkish last name I
like it Dexter mussing ttan is new
member number seven at join pakman.com
remember to if you want don't feel
obligated but if you want use the coupon
code 2020 now that'll chop 66% off of
the cost of your membership let's see
other super chats coming in Blais gamer
says do you reckon it will be a
Bloomberg Bernie race I think that
Michael Bloomberg is going to end up
doing pretty well but I think it will
remain a three candidate race I think it
will be Bernie
Bloomberg and likely one of the other
more establishment centrists
increasingly it looks like not Biden
potentially Pete Budaj edge or Amy
Klobuchar that's that's my sense of it
right now and as I said before I think
there is a very good chance that
Bloomberg ends up actually third in
delegates on the in the Democratic
primary welcome to everybody watching on
twitch for the first time over the
weekend I won I reigned victorious in
the Raj Royale I defeated a gentleman
who goes by the handle airsoft fatty in
a absolutely contentious finale and if
this is your first time watching one of
my streams on Twitch you're one of the
couple thousand people that signed up
followed my channel because of my
victory on the Raj program I you and
appreciate you joining me very very much
a speaking of which I do want to say
thanks to kamiki 1-2-3 for subscribing
with twitch prime very much appreciate
that
Vincent oh sorry no gormer roth says i
hope you will
for office one day that's it that's an
idea Vincent O'Driscoll and James gallon
have both subscribed at the SOI boy
level on my You Tube channel
Mike K says good to see Biden performing
like the horse faced pony soldier that
he is I never know how to pronounce this
ketse coital the serpent goddess says
hoping for a Burnie Tulsi yang
triumvirate
listen yang and Tulsi are they're not
they're not they're not gonna win I
don't know I don't know how else to say
it I don't know if I still have two by
the way I don't even know if I would
this is so toxic I don't know if I even
want to get into it but on Wednesday or
Thursday last week I did a story saying
Iowa shouldn't go first
Iowa shouldn't go first because Iowa is
not demographically representative of
anything
Iowa shouldn't go first because we
shouldn't have a caucus go first we
should actually get rid of caucuses or
cocci as I like to say plural altogether
that's a joke by the way and I said I'm
not insulting Iowans and someone said
David I cancelled my membership because
you're offending you're being so
disrespectful to Iowans and it's like
you know what can I do I issue these
disclaimers people get mad and say David
that's an idiotic disclaimer you
couldn't possibly believe that you were
insulting Iowans when you said Iowa
shouldn't go first in case in point
someone cancelled their membership
because I said I really shouldn't go
first it's you know what can I do anyway
Paul Jacoby says I'm starting to get a
burning sensation when pissing clear
sign were winning I would talk to a
urologist about that anacott patil sends
a 200 I know I always forget that must
be is that the Indian currency rupees I
believe what do you think will happen to
the Biden campaign if Biden doesn't
overwhelmingly win in South Carolina
it's probably over for him if Biden I
mean listen Biden is coming in fifth
right now Biden came in fourth in Iowa
it's all not happening I you know
sometimes I like to say it's all
happening
it's all not happening for Joe Biden
very very clearly let me say a few other
thank-yous I want to say thank you to
Jonathan salata who is new member number
eight of the evening Michael Tattler is
new member number nine I really
appreciate your support very very much
and did I miss anybody else no I think
that's it
I think I'm caught up yes I am caught up
thank you very much we do have the best
way to support the all all streams but
in particular this one is to use the
code 2020 now and sign up at join
pakman.com our goal is 50 new members
why 50 because there's 50 states that's
why and we are currently at nine very
exciting stuff super chats continue to
come in great to hear from folks in the
audience ultra sane says do you find it
difficult to keep up with chat uh
I'm mostly paying attention to super
chat and then messages coming in via
twitch Prime and that is that is very
very good stuff let's see here what am I
so I'm getting some interesting messages
here that there may be a call happening
at the top of the hour at 8:00 p.m. so
at 8 p.m. in in three minutes we can go
over to the live coverage happening with
the Washington Post as well as over on
PBS and see if indeed a call is made as
of right now what we have with 7 percent
reporting Bernie Sanders in first place
with a 5.3 percentage point lead over
Pete Budaj edge at 22 for Amy Klobuchar
continuing to drastically overperform
her polling at 19.7 Lissa booth Warren
at 12 to Biden embarrassing at 7 5 and
then you've got you know a few people
with a little bit of the vote you've got
Tom Steyer Andrew yang Tulsi you've got
some write-ins Duval Patrick is below
that he's off-screen because he's
actually solo let me say thank you and
welcome to red wolf 8 actually the
minute
I didn't miss anybody here red wolf 8
who subscribed with on Twitch Davi so
with the message good job in the growth
at twitch David keep it up
odd shaman cheered some bits the apex
wolf subscribed with prime and the mini
squish has also subscribed with twitch
prime thank you so much I very much
appreciate that dillinger sladac no
sorry I always say this wrong and let me
scroll back up Dillinger sciatic says
it's ed the pac-man yes Tim OS did you
see Biden and Fanta lysing the
disability advocate very cringe and
telling how moderates feel about
disabled folk I didn't see that
I saw him call a woman a dog-faced pony
soldier though will nurse wonderful
world says at what point do you think
yang slash Tulsi call it quits
honestly it's got to be soon but they'll
probably stay until the first four
primaries are are over at least Ricky
Williams says rumor has it Biden was
telling crickets to vote for someone
else at his rally last night big if true
did not hear that KJV 35 has retracted a
super chat
Daniel Rivera media will say New
Hampshire doesn't matter after Bernie
wins listen New Hampshire matters less
than it has in a long time but it's
still important every win is a win every
win is a proof of viability in a
different geographical location among a
different electorate so every win is big
but it is true that this race Super
Tuesday is going to determine what's
going on here after Super Tuesday
Michael Bloomberg may be a very viable
contender here I believe that he will be
much more viable than some people
believe Super Tuesday will determine who
is going to be the establishment shot is
it going to be Biden increasingly the
answer seems no is it going to be Peter
Ami
increasingly the answer seems may be so
let's see now what is happening it is
now 8:00 p.m. in the East 5:00 p.m. in
the West and so far no calls yet we see
a number of different regions
leaning towards different candidates and
it looks as though so far there is no
call being made remember that last
Democratic primary Bernie Sanders
defeating Hillary Clinton so
overwhelmingly in New Hampshire that it
was called now at 8:00 p.m.
also vermin supreme who I was hanging
out with in New Hampshire last primary
came in fourth with 268 votes a lot of
people don't remember that also a lot of
people don't remember that Stephen Roy
Lipscomb ended up with 15 votes in New
Hampshire that's an interesting bit of
trivia from from from last time around
okay
Serg mix-a-lot and troy liege have
subscribed with twitch prime know
messages I very much appreciate the
support I want to say thank you to
Jeremy Tucker Jeremy is new member
number 10 of the evening I want to say
thanks to Harrison Jordan who is new
member number 11 of the evening Denis
van der Zee is new member number 12
John Tyler is new member number 13 lucky
13 very much appreciate that we are
targeting 50 new members 10 like this is
for tonight that's not for this week
that's not for this month that's tonight
folks we are targeting 50 new members
tonight at join pakman.com the numbers
continue to come in we now are up to
nine percent reporting Bernie Sanders
still in the lead
Pete Budaj and Amy Klobuchar are in a
fight for second place distantly behind
Elizabeth Warren and even further behind
Joe Biden if by the time we get to 15
percent Elizabeth Warren is not I would
say within five points of Amy
I believe that Warren is done and that
this will essentially be a race between
Bernie Pete and Klobuchar if Bernie
maintains a five percentage point lead
as we close in on 35 or even 40 it's
going to be tougher and tougher for
anybody to to over to overtake Bernie
Sanders
welcome if you're joining us it is
primary day in New Hampshire our
friendly neighbors to the north here in
Boston we are watching live results come
in now with 10% reporting we are taking
questions and comments on YouTube by
super chat on twitch with subscription
messages and we are anxiously awaiting
what will ultimately be final results
here tonight as a quick reminder Bernie
Sanders easily winning the Democratic
primary in New Hampshire in 2016 it's by
almost a two-to-one margin also polling
going in today as you can see on screen
Bernie Sanders leading followed by Budaj
edge and Klobuchar Warren and then Biden
globish Tarr Warren and Bide and
essentially all tied for third I
predicted coming in that we were going
to see the greatest over performance by
Amy Klobuchar and so far that is very
very much happening if you were hoping
Amy Klobuchar was getting out soon it is
not happening after today and I was
seeing interviews with her aides
indicating that she is going to be
making a tour of some of the different
of Super Tuesday States very Super
Tuesday election states very very soon
some people are suggesting we switch to
The Washington Post New Hampshire
results that they are more updated let
me take a look at that they may not be
as advantageous for the screen they are
ahead though 14% let's see what it'll
look like if I pull those up I'm glad to
switch to those but I want to make sure
we can all see them ya see the layout of
the screen oh boy and all sorts of
things are happening the layout is not
as good and I don't know the exact right
way to get it all looking right let me
see if we've got anything else here I
don't love it guys yeah I'm not I'm not
loving it the the display on the New
York Times I prefer the fake news New
York Times results layout to the Amazon
Jeff Bezos Washington Post layout today
because I want everybody to be able to
see what we
are talking about here okay other super
chats that have continued to roll in
Timmy Lunsford says I haven't been able
to listen to you lately is Trump still
the winner of the general in your
opinion you're the best you know I don't
I don't want to be defeatist ty let's
just work through the process but if you
look at the betting odds there's no
doubt that Donald Trump is still quite
well positioned in general in this in
this in this election grundle grump do
you have a favorite political cartoon I
don't even have a political cartoon to
to even mention I just never look at
political cartoons people coming in
asking whether Tulsi has won yet she has
not yet won she has not yet won and we
will see how long it takes her to win
James B says David would you rather be
forced to watch every album of Kidz Bop
non-stop or Pete the cheat win by a
rigged election you know because I have
no clue what Kidz Bop is I I would not
be able to comment KJV 35 says any
chance you open the phones tonight yes
there is absolutely a chance dream of
the 90s says how many hours per day do
you think Buddha edge spends in front of
a mirror practicing this sounds like
Obama that's good I like that that's
very very good
oh sorry these are coming in so quickly
that it's starting to scroll let me go
back up oh boy super chats just flying
in folks absolutely flying in let me see
here okay here we go just in Ward any
new results not quite yet Justin Ward
says I'm ecstatic about Bernie's chances
tonight why is it though that I sense a
disturbance in the force
hard to say thanks to Roger Rivera for
the YouTube subscription Matthew McDole
appreciate it let me say a few twitch
thank-yous I remember you guys on twitch
you guys are not chopped liver I
appreciate you let me say thanks to JP
fern 81 for the twitch Prime
subscription and vvl Rando for the
twitch Prime subscription thank you very
very much I also want to say thanks to
Jeremy may lock I hope I'm pronouncing
that correctly Jeremy is
you member number 14 this evening if
you're wondering how do you support the
David Pakman show channel and the
streams and all this stuff you probably
have no idea because I never mention it
so I'll tell you the best way is just
grab a membership at join pakman.com all
the info is right up there above my head
we've got a 66 percent off coupon code
2020 now which will save you two thirds
and then everybody cheers and people
love it and I thank you and it's just a
great great thing to do at at join
pakman.com as the results continue to
roll in Bernie Sanders holding a lead
currently let's see VRS high def 23 says
due to recent revelations do you not
think that Bloomberg's campaign might be
obliterated at this point what
demographic could he pick up yeah our
good friend Benjamin Dixon putting out
very very brutal vial I do from
Bloomberg today and we will have to wait
and see what the polling what polling
how polling changes for Bloomberg on the
basis of Ben Dixon's stunning stunning
revelations let's see here what else do
we have
Betazoid says can your team please
upload the bonus show before the regular
show on the Apple podcast member feed
that way it's the correct order for
listeners you know we just yeah let
we'll deal with that that's that's an
issue I am getting messages from people
claiming that Andrew yang is done Andrew
yang is done according to a whole bunch
of different people Andrew yang is
dropping out ladies and gentlemen I said
five minutes ago that he should do it
and indeed Andrew Yang is out now I know
that there are still yang gangers who
are going to tell me that yang is about
to corner the market and is going to win
but Andrew yang himself is suspending
his campaign
Andrew yang Twitter let's see the
announcement from Andrew yang Andrew
yang says okay that's not it uh-oh I
guess he hasn't tweeted
yet I am so proud of this campaign thank
you to everyone who got us here okay so
apparently has not yet announced it but
breaking news ladies and gentlemen
Andrew yang is suspending his campaign
and not hugely surprising I mean we you
know I we've been saying for a while
that he doesn't he doesn't have a shot
and indeed Andrew yang making good on
that let's see what who if anybody
andrew yang gets behind or if he simply
says we got a vote for whoever is the
eventual Democratic nominee Andrew yang
out yes indeed d Smitty asks do you want
Tom Brady to stay with the Patriots I do
but we have bigger fish to fry tonight
Vincent O'Driscoll says greetings from
Island Ireland hoping Bernie lights fire
for a worldwide movement other countries
can't believe the corruption and
cheating going on love the show thank
you hair routine
Damir ian says will Armenia be mentioned
in the election I don't know good
question
Sean Walker how can the DNC screw this
up they always can appreciate the super
chat from Livingstone Col Steven Davis
says should Liz drop out hurting Bernie
can't win the nomination I don't see a
path for Warren to the nomination you're
absolutely right I can't imagine her
dropping out if she keeps getting close
to 15% in a bunch of different states I
don't imagine we will see her drop out
let me say thank you and welcome to
Ernesto more Ernesto more is new member
number 15 of the evening at join
pakman.com appreciate the support
Ernesto thank you very much kwb asks who
would you pick for Bernie's VP I have
decided I'm not talking VP until we know
of who the nominee is going to be I do
what one step at a time Ricky Williams
has donation to pick a question from the
chat all right let's take a look here
questions from the chat questions from
the chat alright question from the chat
is will the yang bot stop claiming
andrew yang is going to win now that he
has dropped out
I don't know I actually still I I
believe there will still be some yang
gangers who may be just satirically will
keep saying he could win with like a
write-in campaign or something like that
Daniel Huberman says yang is suspending
his campaign tonight yes indeed
Dillinger si addict says Bernie's second
choice of 35 percent of warn supporters
Bernie is the second choice of 35
percent of war and supporters what are
your thoughts yes not surprising those
are those numbers have been similar for
a while
Thomas Shomo says David switched to Vox
New York New York Times results are
super behind all right let's look at Vox
New Hampshire results will get let's see
if we can get these updated all right
these might actually work for us oh god
this is not good let me see if I can
actually I think I might be able to do
this there we go beautiful
okay let's zoom it in a little bit and
then now boom I love it
okay race wide results oh god what is
happening there it is alright very good
so this is with a 25 percent reporting
thank you for the suggestion with 25
percent reporting Bernie Sanders still
in the lead ahead of Pete Budaj edge Amy
Klobuchar in third warned fourth Joe
Biden fifth steyr Gabbard yang stired
Gabbard yang following behind very very
important stuff let me say thanks to a
few people over on Twitch Bundang boy
has subscribed with prime verkaik 87
says I hope someone picks up Andrew
Yang's policy proposal for universal
basic income seems as though it would
change the country for the better we
will see if anybody does that we
continue to see Bernie Sanders hold a
lead although a slightly smaller lead
than earlier in the night this is now
with
twenty-five percent 25 percent reporting
let me say thank you to a few other
people who are just amazingly good
people for signing up at join pakman.com
Renae Gaffney ax is new member number 16
of the evening and Denise Russell is new
member number 17 of the evening we do
have a membership target of 50 new
members as you see every time somebody
signs up the bar creeps across the
screen the coupon code 20 20 now saves
you 2/3 2/3 let's continue with Super
chats Livingston Cole has signed up on
YouTube Caleb I hae a--
says you're a cool dude Packman sweating
in the sun at work in new zealand
listening to your stuff it must be what
9:15 in the morning and new zealand is
that right the grizzly progressive says
hey David I'm worried if Buddha edge and
Clovis tower team up Bernie would be on
the ropes what are your thoughts well I
don't know how exactly they would team
up right now uh so I don't I'm not I'm
not sure I understand the idea first in
last kappa says hey David do you think
of either/or yang or Tulsi drop out and
endorse Bernie would that hurt Bernie or
help him I don't think any endorsement
from the current candidates would hurt
Bernie I just don't know how much it
would it would move the needle oh it's
2:15 in the afternoon and New Zealand
Wow so it's uh is that possible with
eight it's wait what so twelve it's 18
hours later in New Zealand that doesn't
sound right
all right well I'm not an expert in time
zones that's for sure haven't claimed to
be Brooks Madden says David I know
you're heterosexual but I decided to
spend $5.00 anyway to let you know that
you're my dream guy somebody please clip
that that's a good standalone upload
super chat for our Instagram page
Allen sach says what do you support
Tulsi driving a Ford in Iowa yeah
someone cancelled their membership to my
show because I said I don't think Ford
makes great vehicles sorry you know but
in any case yes I I don't care what kind
of a car tools he drives through Iowa
hair tearin' coming in with a massive
500 Swedish kronor super chat which is
$51.90 pair says many issues is coming
up
poor Idaho children may the be alive
corona we will find a cure election may
sanity get on top pair thank you
pairs contributions from Sweden always
very much appreciated we are now at
nearly 27 percent reporting we do have
Bernie Sanders still in the lead at
about five point eight percent Pete
Budaj edge second-place Amy Klobuchar
still the biggest over performer we do
know for people asking in the chat that
Andrew yang has ended his campaign we
did know that Andrew yang John yang
everybody every name he has been missed
named as they have all suspended their
campaigns and Andrew yang with about
2300 votes so far in the New Hampshire
primary with 26 percent reporting let me
say thank you to near death I hope
that's not true for the twitch Prime
subscription and doors openness for
subscribing with twitch prime appreciate
both of you Alex Sotelo says Wikipedia
lists Bloomberg and Bernie as Republican
candidates in New Hampshire do you know
if that's correct could Republicans vote
for them today I have no idea about that
but it sounds like a massive distraction
mister Pengo or mr Pengo says whoops
just scrolled up when a bunch of super
chats come in at once they scroll up mr.
Pengo says when should warren drop out
and endorse bernard if she's a
legitimate progressive probably after
Super Tuesday I think if she doesn't
have a path to the nomination after
Super Tuesday she should drop out and
endorse Bernie it's me John B says gave
a like to promote the stream yes welcome
listen if you're just joining us we
somehow have had 24,000 people come
through this stream so far
only 544 have liked the stream my
YouTube rep told me today likes really
help your stream they help YouTube know
to promote your stream over somebody
else's so please hit the like button and
by the way while we're at it please hit
the subscribe button as many of you know
we hit 800,000 subscribers
live on stream last week and we are only
494 away from eight hundred and five
thousand subscribers so like and
subscribe or both very much appreciated
leave a comment that's appreciated
whatever you can do it all it all is
very very much appreciated my phone is
exploding from people shocked that amy
klobuchar is doing so well I I've been
saying it all day Amy Klobuchar
will over perform the polls by the
greatest margin of any candidate tonight
and so far she is doing it she was
polling I believe 11 seven going in and
she is over performing by more than 8
percentage points right now a very
interesting because that does mean she
is gonna be in this thing for a while
let me say thank you to Zach Roddy for
subscribing with twitch prime I
appreciate that
let me thank a few new members Michael
humbler Michael humbler is new member
number 18 thank you so much appreciate
that the place to sign up is join
pakman.com as we are now inching towards
one third reporting one third we're at
twenty seven point two seven percent
Bernie Sanders still with a lead
although the lead has now shrunk at one
point it was 12
Bernie's lead is now down a 4.6 as near
as I can tell
Pete Budaj edge still in a fight with
Amy Klobuchar right around the 20 to 22
percent mark very interesting what is
going on
very very interesting Charles Argyle
says sup DP I love you do you read the
progressive populist or in these times
do you like horror movies very good
questions I don't read it either of
those publications and I do not watch
horror movie
Paul Jacobi says zoom out your screen
you zoomed in earlier to read I think
this is a pretty good zoom level for the
results right do people do people want
to advise me on the zoom level in the
chat I'm glad to adjust if necessary the
only thing I want to make sure of is can
we get back to other stuff easily yes we
can
oh let's listen to Andrew yang n
decompose in this entire race the yang
Yang has fundamentally shifted the
direction of this country and
transformed our politics and we are only
continuing to grow and do n graphing up
angle I'd like to thank my incredible
staff and the hundreds of people who
left their lives and their jobs to join
and build this campaign I know what a
risk that was very few people joined
this campaign because they thought it
was going to be a good career move so
thank you thank you to my team
[Applause]
[Music]
my goal when I first started running was
to solve the problems that got Donald
Trump elected in order to do that I will
support whoever is the Democratic
nominee that's the right thing to say
will he endorse some of them
Andrew yang announcing that he's
dropping out of the presidential race
that's Andrew yang announcing he's
dropping out but Elizabeth Warren is
also coming out to address her
supporters so we're gonna move over to
the warrant event Warren not doing well
today let's see what she has to say
cutting out early hoping to get some
media attention let's see what's going
on senator Sanders and Mayor Budaj edge
had strong night and I also want to
congratulate my friend and colleague Amy
Klobuchar for showing just how wrong the
pundits can be when they count a woman
out stream starting at the fair but
since we are here tonight among family
and friends I also want us to be honest
with ourselves as Democrats we might be
headed for another one of those long
primary fights that lasts for months I
believe we are two states in with 55
states and territories to go
we still have 98 percent of our
delegates for our nomination up for
grabs and Americans in every part of the
country are gonna make their voices
heard
the question for us Democrats is whether
it will be a long bitter rehash of the
same old divides in our party or whether
we can find another way mmm
senator Sanders and Mayor Budaj are both
great people and either one of them
would be a far better president than
Donald Trump this is almost the
concession speech really isn't it this
is very interesting but the fight
between factions in our party has taken
a sharp turn in recent weeks with ads
mocking other candidates and with
supporters of some candidates shouting
curses at other Democratic candidates
these harsh tactics might work if you
are willing to burn down the rest of the
party in order to be the last man
standing they might work if you don't
worry about leaving our party and our
politics worse off than how you found it
and they might work if you think only
you have all the answers and only you
are the solution to all our problems but
if we're going to beat Donald Trump in
November we're going to need a huge
turnout within our party and to get that
turnout we will need a nominee that the
broadest coalition of our party feels
like they can get behind interesting so
Elizabeth Warren despite clarifying that
this is still a fight and there's a lot
that mostly all the delegates are
available she almost sounds like she's
saying whether it's Bernie or Buddha jej
they're both better than Trump and we've
got to get behind the nominee cannot
afford to fall into factions we can't
afford to squander our collective power
we win when we come together it's a
unity speech folks
you know the Reverend Jesse Jackson once
said it takes two wings to fly and I
think he's right our campaign is best
positioned to beat Donald Trump in
November because we can unite our party
we can unite this party and this country
by mobilizing people behind ideas that
are not only popular with huge
majorities of the American people but
that also accomplished structural change
for our broken government and our rigged
economy all right so now Elizabeth
Warren going into more just generic
stump speech type stuff but very
interesting that Elizabeth Warren
currently with 10 percent of the vote
with 30 percent reporting in fourth
place essentially saying listen that
this could be long and I'm staying in it
but it looks like Bernie or Budaj edgers
sort of gonna be the nominees very very
interesting approach and it's a unity
speech in a sense let me say thank you
on twitch for a to a whole bunch of
people signing up with twitch prime
including Xavier Vasco and wood jaguar
artorias cora commie giant duck torts
howl rhino who says only positive thing
from trump is he's revealed just how
close the us's to russia in so many ways
go Bernie if you are just joining us
Elizabeth Warren already giving his sort
of concession speech Andrew yang
completely ending his campaign maybe we
will get lucky and Tulsi will also come
out and say she is ending the campaign
we will continue reading Super chats
from folks as the results come in pyro
plasma says mr. Pakman I've done it I've
stopped racism congratulations Jacob
Perez says did you see yang dropped out
yes I did we just mentioned it
Paul Jacoby that way you could use
updated results cite okay epic fails
yang has suspended his campaign it's me
John B yang suspends campaign print hub
did you see the undecided voter that
said they voted Bernie because of MSNBC
smears while being interviewed by msn
see I did and we're gonna look at that
tomorrow on the show this is Agel hey
just wanted to give you two dollars no
question okay earnest so Seto has
subscribed on YouTube
Jeff H if I die tell Bernie Sanders I
love him particle wave says F in the
chat for the yang gang oh people want to
go back to the speech okay we can go
back to the speech let's say but not my
plan and I have been in this fight
though this fight for working families
for decades
I fought credit card company says they
tried to trick and track consumers i
fought our own banking regulators to
hold them accountable during the
financial crash i fought to build a new
federal agency to protect consumers from
predatory
[Music]
and I got in this fight I ran for office
because I saw that families were being
squeezed harder than ever and too many
politicians were not getting enough done
I'm here to get big things done okay
interesting
because here's the thing about
politicians whether they're offering
vague platitudes or powerful rhetoric
they will ultimately face the same test
actually getting anything done in a
Washington that is badly broken
Americans from all political backgrounds
donate a bunch of flowery words to
explain this they know deep down in
their bones exactly why government
doesn't work for them its corruption and
we need to call it out for what it is
the corruption that gives lobbyists a
louder voice than voters the corruption
that lets big companies pay nothing in
taxes while small businesses pay full
freight the corruption that ensures that
nothing ever changes on gun violence or
climate policy or drug prices even
though nearly everyone in America wants
change and let's be specific here on a
day when career prosecutors showed more
backbone than almost every Republican
senators standing up to this president
Americans of all political stripes are
gravely concerned about the corruption
of a trump Justice Department that
abandons the rule of law to give
sweetheart deals to criminals who commit
their crimes on behalf of Donald Trump
and yes Roger stone I'm looking at you
you deal with that on tonight's show
I'll take this opportunity for a water
week we'll be right back
tonight tonight I have a message for our
party and for this nation our best
chance of beating Donald Trump is with a
candidate who can do the work and I mean
the hard disciplined work a candidate
who can build a campaign to unite our
party and a candidate who can build a
movement that is ready to take on
corruption and win
[Applause]
and the only way we can take on
corruption in Washington is if we're not
beholden to it
let's just check the facts Amy and I are
the only candidates in this race who are
not either billionaires or supported by
super PACs and unlike other candidates
I don't fund my campaign by spending
time behind closed doors sucking up to
wealthy donors is powered by you it is
powered by people and over the past year
I've had the chance to shake hands or
hug way over a hundred thousand people
[Applause]
20 town halls in 29 states in Puerto
Rico and you know there are a lot of
differences among us we come from
different backgrounds different
religions languages and experiences we
have different dreams and different
aspirations we feel the urgency of this
moment in different ways but with all of
those glorious differences for the most
part we want the same things we want an
America where decisions in Washington
aren't bought and paid for by lobbyists
and big donors we want an America where
every person has a voice in our
democracy
we want an America where fossil fuel
companies don't have a vice grip
on our planet an America where we can
breathe the air and drink the water
and America where every child can dream
big and actually have a chance to make
it because no matter the color of your
skin who you love how you worship or
what zip code you live in you deserve an
America where you are safe and your
opportunities are just as good as anyone
elses
[Applause]
I can see that American that America is
within our reach and if you can imagine
that America if you think it's worth
fighting for then join us go to
Elizabeth Warren calm right now pitch in
a few bucks
sign up to volunteer get involved with
our campaign this moment will not come
our way again
[Music]
[Applause]
tonight
hmm it feels like a concession speech
for the entire thing you'll talk about
that in there tonight I'm here to say
thank you thank you to every volunteer
thank you to every organizer to every
doorknocker to every phone banker for
every $5 donor thank you thank you for
helping build a movement to take back
our democracy and to rebuild it from the
grassroots up and while I'm thanking
everyone I want to take just a moment
where are you to thank my sweetie Bruce
[Applause]
the thing Brewster not doing I also
wanna thank the good boy who posed for
one selfie after another
[Applause]
who do you think we're in the fight to
save our democracy is an uphill battle
but our campaign is built for the long
haul and we are just getting started
I am grateful down to my toes for what
our campaign has been able to us to
accomplish so far my plans for this
country have been influenced by letters
pressed into my palms by little girls my
will to fight has been strengthened by
the people who have whispered their
dreams in my ears my determination to
lead a movement has been forged by the
tens of thousands of people who have
said they are ready to fight for an
America they know we can be because if
we have the hope that comes with
dreaming big if we have the courage to
fight hard we are going to win
Wow so Elizabeth Warren giving a speech
that on the one hand is about her
campaign but on the other hand felt very
much like a concession speech and
repeating multiple times that both
Bernie and Pete are great options of
course Bernie and Pete currently locked
in a battle for first place in New
Hampshire the lead now four point eight
percentage points for Bernie Sanders
Elizabeth Warren in a distant fourth
place and of course conceding the
evening as we know exactly what is going
on mathematically no longer really a
possibility that Warren would come back
and win let me say thank you to some
folks and then I want to get back to
your questions Thomas Carter is new
member number 19 on my website Thomas
thank you so much I really appreciate
your support
Sharon Hart lling is new member number
20 Thank You Sharon Francois lardo is
new member number 21 Richard
owes or Oggy I don't know which
pronunciation is correct you are new
member number 22 and Rick stole you were
new member number 23 this evening I
really appreciate everybody supports
there have been a lot of streams they've
been long but we are we are doing it and
really appreciate everybody who has been
contributing one way or the other
norge a pap says with a $50 super chap
tying parity runs big super chat of the
day we really have to talk about
infrastructure spending costs Spain is
getting about 20 times as much
infrastructure as us per dollar at the
extremes new york east side access we're
spending a hundred times as much for
subways on a per kilometer basis for
billion per kilometer versus 43 million
per kilometer okay infrastructure a very
big topic kwb how much money to give us
your choice for Bernie VP it's not about
convincing me to tell you I just haven't
thought about VP because I'm just
focused on presidential parity Ren says
it is 2:15 in the morning in Sweden well
it must be 239 a.m. now thanks for
staying up late with us pare the Kiwi
industry oops sorry about that where did
the Kiwi industry go says love your show
from Guam giancarlo cheery bow says get
yourself something nice
incredible TV TV I am a simple man
I see Pakman on YouTube live and I throw
them a couple dollars keep up the good
work man thank you
Rd thinner thanks for the super chat kwb
can you please solve this math problem
to pay respects to the yang campaign 34
divided by 2 times 3 times 17 in
parentheses okay well that's 34 51
because I think you do parentheses first
51 and then now the thing is I actually
can't tell is it 17 times 51 or is it
134 divided by 102 because of the
spacing and the formatting I'm having a
little difficulty with it so I'm gonna
I'm gonna keep going house says do you
think it would be helpful for Bernie to
use the term welfare state instead of
social democracy no I would not do that
part a cool wave says F in the chat for
yang rip for the gang and smash that
like button yes indeed please if you
were watching on YouTube hit the like
button please if you are watching on
twitch hit the follow button these
things are free folks and they really
help our stream be recommended by
YouTube and if you are on YouTube by the
way I would actually appreciate you not
only hitting like but hit subscribe as
well because we are now down to just 462
subscribers from eight hundred and five
thousand which is a nice round big
number let's see what else we have going
on nothing
nothing too interesting we will go to
speeches although we are not seeing any
other speeches right now so we will stay
on the live results where bernie is
holding about a four point eight
percentage point lead over Pete Budaj
edge Pete holding about 3% over Amy
Klobuchar and then Warren right around
ten Biden below that nobody else really
has a shot I would like
see a Tulsi drop out tonight I think
that that would be a nice show of logic
and reason amy klobuchar continuing
could be the big over performer as I
predicted that she would be and that
race tightening just a little more now
down to only a four point four percent
advantage for Bernie slipping a little
bit
started at about 12 let's see here Emily
Greece says hello from Canada sorry to
hear about your president hope it gets
better soon thanks Emily appreciate that
let me do some twitch thank-yous I want
to say thanks to you mr. Rallo for the
twitch prime sub says thanks for all the
news coverage not bought out and oh no I
lost it now I can't see it
I'm sure it was a very nice message RINO
subscribed with twitch Prime Chris most
once subscribed with twitch prime Dilys
or has subscribed with twitch prime very
much appreciate that guys thank you so
much I think the reason Amy is over
performing is that if you look at the
polling coming in Amy Klobuchar was in
the middle Amy Klobuchar is the black
line here oh boy we can't see a damn
thing let me scroll down and then let me
see if I can do this
there we go oh you still can't see it
okay Amy Klobuchar recently there you go
see this big uptick the black line Amy
Klobuchar polling ended a few days ago
and it's very clear that she was in the
middle of an upswing when the last
polling was done and therefore I am not
surprised that she is actually polling
better she's doing better than the
latest polls showed let me say thank you
to controlled chaos 1982 for the twitch
prime sub I appreciate that let's thank
some new members Kurt Bollinger is new
member number 24 of the evening Kurt
thank you let me also say thanks to Jaz
Hayes who is new member number 25 of the
evening if you're wondering like what
the hell is this membership nonsense we
do have a membership program at join
pakman.com
we have a coupon code where you save
two-thirds 66% and everybody who signs
up I personally think we are halfway to
our goal of 50 and it's it's an amazing
thing let's continue seeing super chats
Michael price says Bernie Bros and yang
gangers unite plenty of room in Bernie's
tent yes the yang gangers should not go
home they should not take their ball and
go home and they should not go vote for
Trump they should vote for whoever is
the eventual Democratic nominee okay
Zachary Monroe have you heard about
Trump's new budget proposal it's
disgusting also do you watch Sam cedar
Ferren cousins or Jesse dolla more I
don't watch any political talk shows I
know Sam and Ferran personally they're
friends of mine I'm going to see them in
a few weeks I don't know nor watch Jesse
dollar more but I've heard that he's a
very nice guy Neena 77 says don't know
how super-delegates work Trump
supporting relative believes because of
super-delegates Bernie doesn't have a
real chance any thoughts as of right now
super-delegates are not allowed to vote
in the first round at the convention
meaning Bernie or whoever would need to
secure the nomination on the first round
or super-delegates get to vote now that
being said the DNC is considering
allowing super-delegates back into the
first round their number of reports
including in Politico about that if they
did that it would be a huge liability
for Bernie Sanders for sure parity Ron
says I will not fall in sleep oh we lost
pare-pare fell asleep it's very late in
Sweden Ian Jones says New Hampshire is
one of the easy wins states for the most
progressive politicians yeah listen
this matters and it doesn't it's not the
be-all end-all Bernie won 62-38 in 2016
and lost the nomination it's momentum
it's proof of concept it's early PR but
you still got to go out and do well on
Super Tuesday
I think Super Tuesday is going to tell
us more that we're going to know so much
more on March 4th about who is really in
this thing
for the for the long haul let me say
thank you to Daddy Dean machine for
subscribing with twitch prime we now
have 1048 twitch subscribers and I would
love to make it 1,100 tonight so I
really appreciate everybody over on
twitch if you are new to my streams and
you heard about me because I was on the
ROG Royale on Saturday welcome I did as
many of you know defeats a gentleman who
goes by airsoft fatty and I encourage
you to check out my incredible victory
that took place on Saturday evening do
check out airsoft Fatty's youtube
channel or twitch channel as well I
believe airsoft fattie is one of the
great contemporary entertainers
currently very very funny stuff on his
channel Lukas Warner says why isn't
Bloomberg on the ballot I'm not a
supporter Bloomberg has just skipped
Iowa and New Hampshire and I don't even
know if he's on the ballot in Nevada and
South Carolina
Bloomberg's going right to Super Tuesday
hut-hut she hut-hut she says saludos
bernie is like us is Jose Mujica the
former president of one of my favorite
countries who I very interesting thank
you we now have 41 percent reporting in
New Hampshire Bernie Sanders is holding
a lead although the lead is shrinking
with every update with peace and love I
am merely the messenger
Bernie started the evening with a 12
percentage point lead it shrank to ten
eight six five point eight five point
two four point eight four point four and
now Bernie's lead is down to four point
two five by my very quick math four
point two five the gap also tightening
between Pete Budaj edge and Amy
Klobuchar Warren has already conceded
for the evening Biden has left New
Hampshire and is already in South
Carolina nobody else has a shot nobody
else has a shot as of right now teach me
guitar says Bernie should do another
simon and garfunkel ad there's an eye
yeah effect says did you see the news
anchor trying to dismiss the Bloomberg
recording because Ben Dickson's a Bernie
supporter he was on CNN I did see it and
it was pathetic I was texting all day
today would then about the whole thing
cereal famine says horsemen from
Manitoba already mrs. Andrew yang all
right
waiting to fade David Warren just said
that she and Klobuchar are the only
candidates who aren't billionaires or
funded by a super PAC yes I believe she
used that line at the last debate right
if I recall correctly let me say thank
you to Brian fro Brian fro is new member
number 26 of the evening really
appreciate that Brian join Brian be a
good person I don't care
your nationality your religion your race
your ethnicity your sports allegiances
just be a good person and grab a
membership at join pakman.com the coupon
code 2020 now saves you 66 percent and
it pushes the blue bar across the screen
we are 52 by my math 52 percent of the
way there let's see what else we have
going on talking to some voters as there
are speeches we will take the speeches
live currently mm-hmm we do not have
them the oh the PBS results are very
very far behind what we have on screen
where we have 42 percent reporting and
Bernie's lead it's shrinking again it
just went from 4.25 percent to now four
point one two percent but Pete Buddha
judge stretching his lead over Amy
Klobuchar or Clos Bakar as she is known
in some circles if you are just joining
us we do not yet have a declared winner
in the New Hampshire primary we got our
first sort of serious results about 50
minutes ago roughly and we are
continuing to follow Ike fan says I saw
Vox at 40 Oh
we just lost super chats hold on I saw
box at 40% then went back Pete was
winning
I see Vox currently at 42% as you can
see here Vox currently at 42% Nathaniel
Brown says David I know this is a little
off-topic but I think you should speak
to an attorney about suing ami Siskin
for defamation and interference with
prospective economic advantage or the
equivalent in mass yeah okay it is off
topic we'll deal with that later
take dressler says no question but we're
still waiting for that shirtless insta
pic love the show there are shirtless
pictures with me on Instagram they are
just kind of old the weirdest thing
happened I tend to get like 30 or 40
Instagram followers a day and yesterday
I got 300 and I can't figure out why I
didn't post anything that did
particularly well over the weekend I
posted a video of me spinning in an
office chair which somehow people went
absolutely cuckoo for cocoa puffs over
but I don't know what happened yesterday
somehow I picked up several hundred
Instagram followers very weird but if
anybody knows about how I could even
figure out what caused that I I welcome
the help Daphne moon how can warren
claim that Sanders has super PACs well
she's being coy she's not saying Bernie
has a super PAC but you can't prevent a
super PAC from supporting you and I
think that's what she is underhandedly
alluding to Miguel Palacios by Lasius of
course means palaces in Spanish who do
you think wins South Carolina you know I
still think that it's conceivable that
Biden wins South Carolina let's look at
the polling there's nothing oh actually
we do have a new polling oh wait no we
don't we do have one new poll in South
Carolina and it has Biden plus 18 at 37
to 19 do we believe Tom Styer is in
second place in South Carolina maybe
he's been spending beaucoup bucks there
so it's certainly certainly conceivable
certainly conceivable okay let's see
where we are with the latest update the
latest update which gets us to nearly 44
percent reporting has Bernie Sanders
ahead by four
point one six percent four point one six
percent let me say thank you to people
for the twitch prime sub bladdy Miao has
subscribed and says hi David my wife and
I can't thank you enough for the
exceptional coverage you provide and
your dedication to presenting forthright
rational content I have been a member
since the start of the year keep up the
great content that's such a nice message
thank you I also want to say thanks to
Strazza who has subscribed with twitch
Prime Alexander I'd says Bennett is out
- all right Andrew yang out and Bennett
out I still see people in the chat
saying somehow yang is going to win I
assume people are joking at this point
Chris X says bill weld has a higher
percentage share of the Republican
primary then Joe Biden has in the
Democratic primary that is incredible
and it shows how poorly Biden is doing
Caleb taya says why is American politics
sounding like an America's Got Talent
show because the president is a reality
show host quite frankly oh do we have
Jimmy from is Jimmy from Philly in the
chat
it seems that Jimmy from Philly has
arrived oh he has yeah psychonaut LSD
user instead of alcohol consumer Jimmy
from Philly is here maybe we'll hear
from him later
Rd thinner says love Bernie but he used
to support Marxism what are your
thoughts not even gonna go into that
Cassiano Battaglia most of MSNBC say bad
things about Bernie doom from 9:07 says
eat the rich no actually I'm sorry doom
from 907 says nothing ye the rich says
support Bernie by supporting progressive
media Waller is me says do you ever
watch the YouTube channel some more news
they put out a great piece on how the
media has treated Bernie I don't
Cody and I follow each other on Twitter
but I don't watch any politics on
YouTube David Adams says what super PAC
is Bernie with I have no idea my guess
is I we should look into that I want to
know exactly what a loser
Warren's alluding to my guess is when
Warren does not include Bernie in the
list of people not not being supported
by super PACs there may be a super PAC
that is supporting Bernie despite of
course not being affiliated with him
because he has no super PAC that I know
of
Danielle Goldman says tulsi is gonna win
big in Nevada then win it all
Russia 2020 okay yeah very very good as
we are about to crest fifty percent
reporting I want to say thanks to uncle
Abreu
who is new member number 27 tonight era
clip Ness is new member number 28
Bailey Frey is new member number 29 and
Daniel Allen is new member number 30
Daniel thank you so much I really
appreciate everybody's support and we do
have a target of 50 new members we are
60% of the way there the coupon code
2020 now will save you 66 percent no
other speeches happening yet we have 45
percent reporting Bernie growing his
lead since the last update back over
five percentage points three and a half
points
now separate Pete Budaj edge and Amy
Klobuchar I see some people in the chat
saying Tulsi is announcing that she is
out I don't know is if that's true I
know people notified me if that yang was
out I don't know if people are kidding
that Tulsi is out can anybody confirm or
am I just being trolled do we know
unclear I guess we don't know
nobody has any idea very good Julie
Anderson has subscribed on YouTube
appreciate that
Dunstable Ramsey says you only listen to
people with money like pay to play
politician listen we've got twitch Prime
subscription messages super chats people
signing up video speeches whatever the
chat is moving so quickly with nearly
4000 live viewers the actual let me see
what the actual chat rate is there are
there's a message almost every second it
is difficult to to pay attention to the
to the chat okay I'm being told that
Tulsi is speaking on c-span let's see if
we can get video of that bear with me
yeah I'm not finding that right now but
maybe it will be carried shortly we have
video from the Bernie Sanders let's take
let's take a quick listen I want to be
President
they're trying to make a calculation
that's very very different decision and
so Andrew yang is this person who is
this character but he hasn't been like
someone just could be president let's go
now to Ronda Colvin
let me I'm here with our colleague
Alexandra Petri who is also attending
the Klobuchar our party and doing some
reporting here it looks like there is
not actually any news happening right
now so we will go back to our results
closing in on 50 percent reporting
martin van Gorp says keep up the good
work
greetings from Belgium love Belgium
great to hear from you Tristan mcoppins
says if Trump wins 2020 he will remove
term limits by 2024 no I don't actually
think that that will happen
Neal merchant says hi David love your
channel been following since it was
recommended a couple years ago by my
good friend Chantal from Brussels oh I
hope Chantal is doing well speaking of
Belgium thank you for always delivering
honest and insightful content yeah
Chantal and I have missed each other the
last couple times I've been in Europe
she was traveling and great to hear from
you Neal doom from 907 sends another
super chat Daphne moon says tulsi sent
out an email saying she's continuing
okay very good we are caught up with
super chats if you have a message
question or whatever you want up on the
screen you can send it via super chat
it'll show up in the bottom left or you
can send it with a twitch sub and it'll
show up at the top Gilmore goth says
can't wait for Bernard Sanders to be my
president with a twitch Prime
subscription mr. Gonzalez says brief
research shows a pack of nurses unions
and political activists supports Bernie
there you go my int my imagination was
my instinct was Warren wouldn't say it
unless it was defensible in some way let
me welcome and say thank you to race
Picou who is new member number 31 of the
evening and jacob jax mark who is new
member number 32 of the evening thank
you so much for the support our goal is
50 new members we are at 32 if 18 people
can get us to 50 i will open up the
phone lines and take phone calls from
you fine folks you can sign up very
quickly at
join pakman.com we are now at 50 I'm
sorry a 47% reporting and Bernie's lead
is as small as it has been
Bernie's lead with the last update has
shrunk to 4.0 eight percent the previous
smallest lead for Bernie was for 2.2 and
with the latest update Bernie's lead has
shrunk even more to three point six five
Bernie's lead as large as 12 and it has
shrunk to three point six five but peat
building his lead over Amy Klobuchar was
a dilly dallying with around a two to
three point lead over Amy peat now
extending his lead over Amy to four
point three this is a three-person race
no one else has a shot Warren is out
Biden literally left the state hours ago
and is in fifth place
Tom Styer and Tulsi both in the three
percentage point range
Andrew yang with four thousand votes has
ended his campaign and that was the
right decision people may not want to
hear it but that was absolutely the
correct decision mathematically okay let
me see what other super chats oh the
super chat scrolled all the way down let
me see here equals gaming says Deepak
dropping by to congratulate you on the
win in the Rajoy al truly a massive
victory in the marketplace of ideas love
your content keep it up yes indeed if
you are just joining me and I welcome
the 3700 of you watching on YouTube
the 830 of you watching on twitch and of
course the 90 of you watching on
Facebook live that's okay that's okay
I did win the Raj Royale on Saturday you
can find the video on the raj youtube
channel when this started as you can see
I was one of I believe 12 different
contestants over time I was able to
persevere and the number of people on
screen went down and down and down until
ultimately
it was just Steven Kenneth destiny
bunnell ii me and a gentleman who goes
by the name airsoft fatty ultimately the
vote eliminated destiny and it was just
airsoft fatty and myself
this is his handle I'm not being
offensive in any way and I did
ultimately win airsoft fatty I was
introduced to his content and I do
believe that airsoft fatty is one of the
great entertainers of our time I truly
do please check out airsoft fatties
YouTube channel it is it is amazing it
is amazing let's go next to David Adams
who says my favorite reply to Trump
supporters on Twitter is yeah good okay
I like that too I like that one too
our Andrew O's sends a $10 super chat
Viper x1 says Washington Post yang and
Bennett just dropped out yes indeed
squirrel dude says Lewis dropped out
who's Lewis I don't even know who that
is green Randy says I simply cannot be
next to cabbage Gordon reads says I am
from Ireland just two questions
what's a caucus I'll wait for your
second question we did an entire segment
on caucuses or cocci the plural or last
week so we're not we're not gonna do
that again let me say thanks to liquid
ice 55 for the twitch prime sub who says
while in town the Baker gives you a
sweet roll delighted you take it into an
alley to enjoy only to be intercepted by
a gang of three kids your age the leader
demands the sweet roll or else he and
his friends will beat you and take it
what do you do I would need to know what
a sweet roll is to know how much I care
about it then I could decide let me say
thank you to Andy Wilcox who is new
member number 33 of the evening at join
pakman.com I so appreciate everybody who
has been signing up at join pakman.com
pay full price or use the discount code
20/20 now either way your membership
fills up this bar and it is now
two-thirds full it is now we are
seventeen members away we are now
basically at 50% reporting in New
Hampshire and Bernie's lead has been
trimmed to three points four five
percent if you have been watching from
the top of the hour you may have noticed
that this is I'm just the messenger
folks okay
don't beat me up every time almost every
time the vote totals are updated
Bernie's lead over booed edge edge
shrinks a little bit okay it was at
12:10 eight six five four point eight
four point four three point eight etc
and it is now down to three point four
five Bernie's smallest lead of the
evening and we are going to continue
monitoring that thanks to lazy normal
girl for subscribing with twitch prime
if you are just joining us on twitch
please make sure you hit the follow
button it's free slam the follow button
if you are just joining us over on
YouTube make sure you hit the like
button it really helps us whenever we
get three four five six thousand likes
on our streams it becomes a vicious
cycle of more and more people coming in
and then more people liking the stream
and more people coming in and I think
you get the idea
make sure to both like and subscribe on
youtube we are now just a few hundred
subscribers away from eight hundred and
five thousand on YouTube which is just
incredible I am being told that Joe
Biden will soon be speaking we will go
to that as soon as it happens
okay we are we are waiting for Joe Biden
I am being told let's see here we now
have a another slight reduction in
Bernie's lead to 3.5 3.5 maybe I'll keep
the results up until someone lets me
know in the chat that Biden is speaking
thanks to fast boat to flavortown for
giving out five subscriptions I
appreciate that let's see other super
chats coming in
Justin Graham says union members for
burning okay Clayton Watson says tunnel
snakes rule Jackson says David I'm going
to have to unsubscribe and cancel my
membership because you said damn on the
Raj Royale podcast no I'm kidding loved
you there thank you I appreciate that
JD Wilder is a Youtube subscriber that
means y'all says if Biden lost South
Carolina do you think he'll stay in know
it Biden's got I think South Carolina is
increasingly a must-win for for Joe
Biden let's see V our side f23 says Raj
has a dating show would you go on it
might be great content I would consider
that I would consider that Gordon Reid
says have you been to Ireland can you
put your caucus on info YouTube can you
put you caucus on info YouTube it almost
sounds that almost sounds like someone's
hitting on me can you put you caucus on
info YouTube I have been only to
Ireland's Airport that's all Jess Stumbo
has subscribed on YouTube Benjamin
Castillo or as we say in Argentina caste
show has sent a super chat which I very
very much appreciate we're keeping an
eye supposedly Joe Biden is going to
speak now interestingly he's already in
South Carolina yeah no it's not a Boston
accent an Argentinian accent Joe Biden
reportedly already in South Carolina
just getting the hell out of New
Hampshire Riley Roseboro says vermin's
supreme just won the New Hampshire
libertarian primary that's funny yeah I
bumped into Berman last primary in in
New Hampshire pasta Pete says David what
do you say to people who don't vote you
should you should there's no excuse for
not voting let me say a few other
thank-yous Edwin Soriano is new member
number 34 at join pakman.com Elmer
Spratt Ling is new member number 35 at
join pakman.com Scott Biermann or beer
man is new member number 36 at join
pakman.com matt johnson is new member
number 37 at
pakman.com Keitha barney is new member
number 38 at join pakman.com and that
gets me caught up 38 out of 50 new
members we are told Joe Biden will soon
be speaking we are now over 51%
reporting and Bernie's lead is down to
three points for eight three point four
eight is Bernie's lead right around
fifty two hundred votes and now Bernie's
lead up to three point five one with the
latest update Bernie now up three point
five one percentage points green randy
says you and i know thats toby face is a
powerful force I wish I knew who that
was
dr. Jude Armstrong says dating show
don't you have a girlfriend oh yeah I
thought I mean I've seen people with
girlfriends do that I thought it was
just a goof just doing the show I didn't
think it was a real like you were
actually trying to find a date Knicks
when says Iowan first last time
caucusing 100% agree with your analysis
liked the idea of starting with multiple
states at once
thank you very much I appreciate that we
have surpassed fifty percent reporting
if anybody is currently calling a
victory I would be interested in hearing
that I'm not seeing that anywhere I'm
seeing it reported a PBS is only at 31
percent reporting our numbers are at
more than 50 percent reporting already
we heard that Joe Biden was reportedly
going to be speaking soon and it has not
happened yet but we are standing by
let's see if there is anybody else who
might be calling it one way or the other
no I'm not seeing any calls so far and
it is very very close
I do see a message yang suspending
campaign read it on suicide watch yes we
already talked about yang suspending the
campaign we are keeping an eye on
that for sure no question about it
we are I wish I knew exactly when it was
that Joe Biden was scheduled to speak I
guess you never really know he's going
to be joining his own event via
television Biden's not at his own event
I guess they sent his sister I don't
know but in any case we are we are we
are I guess waiting to hear from Joe
Biden the vote total yes people are
talking about the vote total Bernie
Sanders is leading Pete by by my count
it looks like 5,000 to 14 is it five to
one four
can somebody double check my math 5 2 1
4 3 - 9 4 3 carrier - 11 carries 4
raised to the seventh power sine cosine
I'm seeing 5 - 1 4 as the margin right
now for for Bernie Sanders 5 to 1 4 okay
people confirming thank you very much
the percentage lead is three point three
point three eight now continuing to just
shrink and again I don't I have no idea
whether we are expecting later on to see
results let me see if I can find the
okay let's refresh this and take a look
when we look at areas still to come so
if you look at Bernie's areas pits
they're actually pretty damn similar
areas it seems to be just the larger
counties basically and we look at where
we are still waiting for votes Bernie
and Pete Bernie see it looks like a lot
of the state is simply proportionately
going to Bernie with the exception of
Rockingham County where Pete has a small
margin all counties are by similar
proportions going to Bernie that's very
interesting so we'll keep an eye on the
numbers and see what happens there the
lead now shrinking by the way into the
twos Bernie's lead now still in terms of
gross numbers actually the the gross
lead has shrunk now to four thousand
four thousand to twenty one or something
like that
the percentage point lead for Bernie is
now down to only two point seven roughly
two point seven point lead for Bernie
let's see here squirrel dude says I'm a
college student do you have any
political science history course
suggestions at UMass Amherst you know I
I was in the econ and communication
departments at UMass Amherst I didn't
take a single Poli Sci class and for
history what did I just don't remember I
unfortunately do not have any
suggestions for you let me welcome the
Prosecco papa on twitch with the twitch
prime sub saying hi dad love your show
thanks son appreciate it let me say
thank you to Patrick - sure Patrick -
sure is new member number 39 at join
pakman.com thank you so much Patrick I
appreciate that we are just 11 members
away from hitting our goal as we are at
53% reporting with Bernie Sanders
holding an increasingly small lead over
Pete Budaj edge now oh and bumping it
back up a little bit now to 326 326 Joe
Biden embarrassingly bad I mean there's
just no other way to put it
I don't believe Joe Biden is gonna drop
out anytime soon but if Joe Biden can't
get a win in South Carolina I think it
starts looking very very ugly for Uncle
Joe Keanu Fabiana says can we trust the
Electoral College to vote Bernie in it
no in fact the Electoral College has
been a huge boon to Republicans remember
that there are multiple presidential
elections where were it not for the
electoral college we would have had a
Democratic president check out my
interview by the way today with Tom
Hartman where he explains how were it
not for voter suppression we would also
have had more Democratic presidents we
are maybe waiting for someone to speak
now I'm doubting whether Joe Biden is
really close to speaking but we will see
Bernie Sanders boosting his lead now
close
again on a four percentage point lead
and it's tightening up a little bit
Pete had built a five-point lead over
Amy Klobuchar now only about a three
point two percentage point lead uh Scott
B says boo oh whoops hold on a second
Buddha judge went up 600 on one update
Bernie zero okay
RJ Williamson says even if half of Steyr
gabbard yang warren votes went to Bernie
if even half he'd have a huge lead
progressives need to consolidate this
vote ASAP yes dinosaur rainbow pancakes
says is the DNC gonna sabotage Bernie
versus Trump we'll deal with that if and
when we get to it
it's me John B says what's a Dogface
pony soldier I wish I knew I have no
idea let me say thank you to Dan cath or
for subscribing with twitch prime if
you're just joining us on YouTube I have
a tiny tiny ask for you please hit the
like button we're trying to get to 3,000
likes and please hit the subscribe
button both of these things are
completely free I mean literally they
cost nothing just start pounding the
like and subscribe buttons because these
things are free and they really do
support our show Bernie Sanders now with
a four percentage point lead and a 6300
vote lead mathematically the door is
closing for Pete Buddha judge okay
remember this is not winner take all
much like I said before the Iowa caucus
this is going to be it's gonna be close
in terms of the number of Delegates
reminding you of course that where do I
have it the delegate counts from Iowa
now what is this including this the
numbers now went up actually I wonder if
what they're including now at this point
are they including anything from New
Hampshire they are starting to add New
Hampshire delegates interestingly enough
but as you can see here Bernie and Pete
with the numbers we have right now no
matter who wins they are going to end up
with a very similar number of Delegates
this is going to be a fight
only after Super Tuesday are we really
going to learn more about the sort of
shape of the race longer term Mitch
visage says David what percentage of
voter turnout is needed to ensure that a
valid result in the general election or
do you think Trump will denounce all but
a win if Trump loses by a small margin
he'll say he really won if he loses by a
big margin he'll say that's an
unrealistically large margin I think
that it was rigged so I believe either
way Trump is going to question the
results listen Trump won in 2016 and he
still questions the results just imagine
what the guy will do if he loses okay we
are continuing to be told that Biden is
close to speaking when he does we will
put it up on the screen the vote
continuing to fluctuate between a two
and a half and four point lead for
Bernie Sanders in New Hampshire Mike K
says do you think it would help her hurt
Bernie if he plays up the conspiracy of
IO being Iowa being rigged and blamed
the DNC for trying to screw him over
Bernie has gained support on issues and
policy so if I were him I would stick to
that instead of talking about admittedly
valid complaints
Patrick r-22 says how much does a twitch
subscription pay you I'm a subscriber
already and I have twitch prime and
don't use it I not allowed to say that
actually because of the the twitch Terms
of Service it's crazy but it's free to
you and we get paid that's the important
thing
Dutch Morgan says in the Chuck Todd
incident today where he referred to
Bernie bros as an online mob do you
think Bernie Bros demanding he be fired
to prove his point I think it was
yesterday it seems that I mean what
Chuck Todd was wrong demanding he be
fired it seems like a little bit much
for me
seems like a little bit a little bit
much for me ghost Reaper says I liked
but I'm already subscribed sorry apology
accepted that's okay Jess Stumbo has up
graded their membership to beta thanks
Jess John McLean says Rockingham
switched from Pete to Amy
Bernie is too interesting Jess Stumbo
has upgraded her membership again to
alpha John Henley says David with Joe
Biden tanking at every turn what will
happen to corn pop I wish I knew I wish
I knew it is a it is a big big question
people asking about opening up the phone
lines I will open the phone lines at 50
members we are only 11 members away you
can sign up at join pakman.com the
coupon code is 20 20 now to save 40%
let's see if they are talking about Joe
Biden speaking soon of Michael bloom oh
dear everything going wrong here see
what's going on at burn eh-eh we're here
back in the studio in DC and we have a
really great set of updates for you so
we're running at about 51 percent
reporting which is really interesting
and it means that some of these patterns
that we were seeing early in the night
are starting to become a lot clearer
messages let's talk about some of those
patterns and set up the stage for you
we've got Bernie Sanders in the purple
we've got Pete Buddha judging green boba
char and indigo and Elizabeth Warren and
orange now what we're seeing tonight is
that Bernie Sanders has 27 and a little
bit percent of the vote we've got people
to judge with about 23 and a half we've
got Amy Klobuchar a little under 20% and
we have Elizabeth Warren in a distant
fourth at right around 10 percent this
numbers have not changed too much since
the last time we took I think we all
mostly understand this ok talk about
Jessie small it over on PBS so we'll
keep standing by for speeches
we now have nearly 60 percent reporting
and Bernie's lead is now two point seven
two point seven is Bernie's lead the raw
vote lead is about 4,500 4,500 for
Bernie Sanders let's see
John Henley says oh no we already did
that one ryan Olding says yangyang 2020
he's about to take the lead Val McLin
she asks David when I moved
will I still be valve from Agawam
depends where you move to Val if it's a
cooler place then maybe you'll be valve
from that place
Damon Wells says Chuck Todd didn't just
call Bernie supporters an online
multi-man mob he compared them to Nazis
yeah didn't he say brown shirts from
what I saw
Zenda crust says will warns low numbers
renew Bernie or bust
I think that those are two totally
different questions
Mario Madrigal says any more thought
about the country tour love you yeah I
don't know I don't think I could
realistically do a national tour until
after the election it's just too much to
organize I think let me say thank you to
oh I love this name new member number 40
of the evening is Callistus Taeyang jr.
Callistus Kiwi yang jr. I hope I'm
pronouncing any of those names correctly
very much appreciate the support let's
see here
Matthias Horvat is a new YouTube member
farm dad word barf says subbed on the
website today
I've voice mail the question what
conservative counterpart would you
recommend I support david pakman show on
the left and who on the right no way am
i taking the bait on that one my friend
and I want to thank Anthony for Ruchi
for signing up on YouTube and DDA Mejia
for signing up on YouTube as well we are
now at fifty eight and a half percent
reporting Bernie's lead is 2.75 percent
and just under five thousand votes and
it is it is remaining tight Bernie was
able to pull it up to about four percent
and it is now at about two point seventy
five very very tight they're talking
about Shabalala on PBS newshour so I
think we're gonna stick over here is
this even live yeah it is live okay it
looks like the Washington Post is giving
us
more more updated information very very
interesting okay name withheld says that
Biden is in a strong fifth yes he's
definitely like he's there's no chance
Biden falls into sixth place and that's
something he can be happy about for sure
Colby Moors sent a super chat but then
retracted it we are aware that Andrew
yang has dropped out of the race if you
are just joining us we have nearly 60%
of the vote in New Hampshire reporting
we have already heard a strange sort of
concession type speech from Warren where
she seemed to be conceding the entire
election like the national election but
yet she says she's going to continue it
was weird
Andrew yang has dropped out let me see
if I can get my my earpiece cable is
doing something very very weird a yang
is out I believe Tulsi should end her
campaign but she announced that she is
staying in Tom Steyer is running in
second place in South Carolina he is
likely to pick up delegates there so he
probably has actual you know like he
actually has a case for staying in at
this point in time and Michael Bennett
has also decided to end his campaign
let's see here other questions coming in
we are still waiting for speeches let's
listen to a couple of these supporters
that are being interviewed you know with
nearly no national recognition and now
today we're in second place in New
Hampshire where we won Iowa it's just
it's very fulfilling to see where we've
come and very energized to see where we
here and around the area a lot of people
have been very as we're seeing right now
lobular down between Pete and Bernie
kind of like the more progressive and
more moderate approaches and people's
trying to see their favorites and I
think it's going to be exciting to see
where tonight ends up going from Iowa to
here well thanks Nick
former Vice President Joe Biden is about
to speak right now so we're gonna go to
him let's go to that very good let's
take that speak you guys I've been
coming here a long time when I die I
want to be reborn in Charleston actually
so he's in South Carolina he's not in
your hand his audio level is a very very
[Music]
things maxed I apologize thank you I
can't go any louder I am
I'm Jill Biden's husband I work for
Cedric Richmond and David Mack is taking
me to school look I know some of the
other senators came over they came up to
see me they're in session right now and
I thank them for making the effort
there's so many people here for me to
say thank you thank you thank you so I
just fill placing you folks up and up in
New Hampshire and they did a good job
but I want to tell you the people of
Nevada are watching and I want to make
it clear we praise their diversity as a
state and I'm gonna be out there seeing
them very soon tonight though I just
heard from the first two of date two of
them location
not half patient not a quarter of the
nation were sent to - all right come
from that's the opening bell not the
closing bell and the fight to end Donald
Trump's presidency is just beginning
just for God we're gonna have to go
fight Pope
okay thank you
it is important that I went to vadym
spoken but look we need to hear from
Nevada and South Carolina and Super
Tuesday states and beyond
look we're moving in an especially
important phase because up till now we
haven't heard from the most committed
constituencies the Democratic Party the
african-american community okay and the
fasting of the fastest-growing segments
of society the Latino community I want
y'all think of a number ninety nine
point nine percent that's the percentage
of African American voters who have not
yet had a chance to vote in America one
more number ninety nine point eight
that's the percent of Latino voters
every night a chance to vote
so when you hear all these pundits and
experts cable TV talkers talked about
the race tell them it ain't over man
we're just getting started
listen our votes count too we're not
glad anyone take his election away from
you look I've said many times you can't
be the Democratic nominee and you can't
win a general elections Democrat unless
you have overwhelming support from black
and brown voters it's just really simple
though it's a natural fact it's true
it's absolutely true and folks you know
all those Democrats who won against
incumbents from Jimmy Carter to a guy
named Clintons a guy named Obama my good
friend guess what they had overwhelming
african-american support without it
nobody's ever won no really
and you although you own my heart look
more important since you're not when the
Democratic nomination for president you
shouldn't be able to win it it's not
brown voters too often your loyalty your
support your commitment to this party
have been taken for granted I have never
once in my career since I got involved
as a kid taking it for granted and I
give you my word as a Biden I never
ever ever will now if you want to know
would any other candidates are going to
do in the future the tendencies to look
at the past well I left the law firm
when I was a kid with a great job and a
fancy law firm but and then to become a
public defender to fight for the people
of the community I used to work in an
Eastside because they couldn't afford a
lawyer on the county council I fought
against redlining in the US Senate I
passed the extension the Voting Rights
Act for two decades the Violence Against
Women Act and by the way I had the back
of a great President Barack Obama for
eight years by the way we increased
access to capital for African American
entrepreneurs let's get something
straight
give it a chance they do just as well as
anybody else and quite frankly better
and they build neighborhoods they build
all communities block and I were able to
reduce the federal population and
speaking HBCUs
I got seventy billion dollars coming to
HBCUs not a joke the minority
universities look we saved the
automobile industry past Obamacare we
stopped insurance companies from
discriminating against people with
pre-existing conditions and on top of
all of that we build an economy that
Trump is bragging about
[Applause]
this guy squandered his father's fortune
now he squandered the economy we gave
him they all think I'm kidding I'm not
so much the president instead of talking
about impeaching Barack Obama you should
be saying Thank You President Obama
thank you thank you thank you but folks
look we have so much more to do I
promise you as your president
you will be partners at shaping the
policy to make sure every single
American has an opportunity the thing
that I've never liked and not with water
we'd all be back for years I don't know
what you need best I listen you all the
leaders in the black community no what
you need best we don't listen enough we
take for granted you know what you need
you know what your families need and
I've never not listened to you first we
need to defend and build on Obama care
Trump wants to get rid of it even some
of the folks in my own outfit the
primary I want to take it away but I'll
never let that happen I was proud to
serve as President Obama's vice
president for eight years for the honor
of my life and he'd become a close
personal friend the whole family has
been matter of fact our granddaughters
and his daughters are best buddies they
went to school together for 12 years and
same small class well actually ten years
but they're still hanging out with one
another even though they go to different
schools where are you I'm up in Michigan
stepmother University of Michigan what
are you doing there I came up to see me
like you know anyway all I know is I get
to pay for the plane ticket anyway well
I was never prouder than the day that we
passed Obama care and here's we're gonna
do we're gonna expand out we're gonna
eliminate we're gonna get rid of all the
executive orders that have curtailed it
we're gonna increase funding into
research for finding cures to whatever
families are dealing with cancer
diabetes
[Applause]
african-americans maternal health
disparities look at them in the United
States of America today today there's an
incredible disparity it's sinful it's
sinful it's an indictment of the entire
system and by the way y'all know
education is a great equalizer
we need to treat it that way every child
has the same capacity when they're born
every one of them at the same capacity
every child has deserves a great
education no matter what your zip code
or your income level and I put my money
where our mouth is we're gonna triple
title one funding to give our teachers
the pay raise they need make sure every
every treat by the way we're losing we
already a one hundred and fifteen
thousand teachers shirt by 2025 you're
gonna be a quarter a million short and
who's gonna get shortchanged the people
of you darn right they are and look
we're gonna give every teacher a pay
raise and then dinner that's we're gonna
continue the crippled justice before
that the President Obama and I started
we're gonna end all private prisons and
no more jail time for addiction you go
into mandatory treatment build more
treatment facilities not prison system
and make sure marijuana convictions
their entire records expunged so when
asked by a job application have you ever
been arrested you'll be able to say
legally no I have not folks folks let's
think about this there's so much and by
the way all these states that are out
there legalizing marijuana and
legalizing medical use of it we should
take a big chunk of those profits and
put them into prison reform in treatment
treatment treatment treatment look it's
just an important we have to be a
country of second chances for God's sake
no think about it we all talk about
second chances it what do we do someone
gets out of prison or gets out of a
tough spot we say you're denied all the
things that can help you from returning
to your communities we're going to even
25 bucks in a bus ticket you end up
under I've got to say a big thank you
for to airsoft fati for raiding with a
party of a hundred and fifty eight nine
minutes
ago apologies for only noticing it right
now airsoft fattie one of the great
entertainers of our time very very
impressed with him
let's keep listening to Joe Biden we
will look at the results as we listen to
Uncle Joe we should be teaching them
skills it makes no sense it makes no
sense
to keep it a penal system look for a
great country we have great people we
have the greatest workers in the world
but you should be paid like we're the
greatest workers in your background I
come from not dissimilar except it was
he's the Louisiana I was in Pennsylvania
and Scranton we have too many families
working their tails off just to make
men's meat to many people I know did
with my dad doing you know now here in
South Carolina maybe what I call that
longest walk up a short flight of stairs
and tell their son or daughters honey so
we can't live here anymore daddy mommy
doesn't have a job you're gonna go home
a little grandpa for a while but I'm
gonna gonna make it we're gonna be able
to do it and I'll come back and I'll
make sure when I'm able to get a place
well bring it all together again people
ever had trouble keeping the roofs over
the heads when my dad walked up those
stairs are remembrance 24:46 North
Washington Ave and I'm doing in Scranton
I was in third grade and he looked at me
he said I promise you it's gonna be all
right he believed it was he believed it
and he was right because then if you
took a shot you got a chance you're able
to do it today think of all the people
who can't look at their kids and say
it's gonna do we're gonna be able to do
it because the deck is stacked the way
it is today I mean it really genuinely
is we have two thirds we have over 50%
of all people who are working-class and
middle-class think their children will
never achieve the same standing they had
what a god-awful conflict you know just
makes me mad
look we're gonna invest in our families
in our communities we're gonna invest in
roads and bridges broadband water
systems school buildings rural
infrastructure do people want to hear us
or just to go away to 2030 plan to get
finally to those areas that were been
left behind the bulk of what needs to be
done by the way I make no apologies
anybody for it's an interest of
everybody the wealthy the semi wealthy
the middle class the work that everybody
does better when they do everything
works for everybody everything we got to
make sure black and brown families and
businesses have the same shot that comes
to accumulate wealth all right I think
we get the gist we'll leave it on
because Amy Klobuchar may be speaking
soon let's take another quick look at
the numbers we are now at 65 percent
reporting with 65 percent reporting
Bernie Sanders with about a 45 46
hundred vote lead over Pete Budaj edge
that works out at this point in time to
about two point four five percentage
points it is tight but it will soon
become mathematically likely that Bernie
Sanders will be the winner likely they
will each come away with the same number
of Delegates because of the a
proportional allocation of delegate
delegates let me say thank you to a few
other new members I want to say thanks
to Ryan o Goolsbee Ryan Oglesby is new
member number 41 at join pakman.com and
Jonathan Barker is new member number 42
at join pakman.com we were only 8 new
members away from our goal of 50 new
members if you are just joining us we
are following the results where nearly
two-thirds of the vote has now been
counted Bernie Sanders is in the lead
Amy Klobuchar are now coming out to
speak we will let's see we will listen
to Amy a couple of other super chats
John Wayne Carr Kerr says join a union
anyone can join one there's no excuse
not to
join the IWW if you're more dedicated
John H says is a Warren dropout better
for Peter Bernie I think it's better for
Pete let's listen to Amy Klobuchar are
the biggest over performer of the day
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello America I'm Amy Klobuchar and I
will beat Donald Trump
my heart my heart is full tonight my
heart is full tonight well there are
still ballots left to count we have
beaten the odds every step of the way we
have done it on the merits we have done
it with ideas and we have done it with
hard work because we are resilient and
strong as the people of this great
nation thank you to our incredible staff
and our unstoppable volunteers wonderful
husband John our daughter
[Music]
and the people of New Hampshire because
of you we are taking this campaign to
Nevada we are going to South Carolina
and we are taking this message of unity
to the country we know in our hearts
that in a democracy it is not about the
loudest voice or the biggest bank
account it is about the best idea and
about the person who can turn those
ideas into action we know that we cannot
win big by trying to out divide the
divider in chief
another unity machine know that we win
by bringing people with us instead of
shutting them out Donald Trump's worst
nightmare is that the people in the
middle the people who have had enough of
the name-calling and the mudslinging
have someone to vote for in November
[Applause]
okay I cannot wait to bring our Green
Bus around the countries I cannot wait
to win the nomination cannot wait to
build a movement and win with a movement
of fired up Democrats independents and
moderate Republicans that see this
election as we do we see it as an
economic check on this president we see
it as a patriotism check and we see it
as a decency check because in the end we
know that what unites us is so much
bigger than what divides us and we know
we know that we believe so many of us
believe that the heart of America is
bigger than the heart of this guy in the
White House right tonight is about grit
and my story like so many of yours is
one of resilience I announced my
candidacy in the middle of a Minnesota
blizzard and there were a lot of people
that predicted I wouldn't even get
through that speech but not the people
of my state and not the people of New
Hampshire okay except then they
predicted that we wouldn't make it
through the summer we did then they
predicted we wouldn't make it to the
debates and man were we at the debate in
New Hampshire
what we've been is steady we've been
strong and we've never quit I think that
sounds pretty good for a president
[Music]
across the months and months and miles
of this race we redefined the word grit
you see it with our happy scrappy
campaign you saw it in our ten County 30
hour tour in the middle of a nor'easter
let's not forget that what was - our
early morning diner stops and our late
night rallies and yes you saw it on that
debate stage just like so many of you
out there I know a little bit about
resilience my grandpa worked 1,500 feet
underground in the mines in northern
Minnesota he never graduated from high
school because her his parents were sick
he had nine brothers and sisters and he
had to help raise them and every day he
would go down in that cage in that mine
carrying a lunch bucket that my grandma
would pack his youngest sister Hannah
was only eight years old when they put
her in an orphanage and he vowed after
his parents died that he would go and
get her and two years later he borrowed
a car he went to Duluth and he brought
her home he he and my grandma saved
money in a coffee can in their basement
while she does the coffee cans story
we've all heard a hundred times I just
want to point this out Bernie's lead
over Pete is the smallest it has been
all night now at two point one seven
percent two point one seven percent is
the closest they have been important of
course to understand that this becomes
more and more insurmountable the more
votes are counted because the fewer
votes left to count the more difficult
it is to overcome what is now about a
forty to forty to forty three hundred
vote deficit for Pete Budaj edge but
percentage-wise this is the closest that
it has been all night let's go back to
Amy Klobuchar from the state of
Minnesota
[Applause]
for President of the United States
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
in a country of shared dreams that no
matter where you come from no matter who
you know no matter the color of your
skin no matter where you worship no
matter who you love that you can make it
in the United States of America right I
didn't have a perfect life my dad
struggled with alcoholism his whole life
and by the time John and I got married
he got his third DWI and then the judge
said to him you got to decide jail or
treatment and he chose treatment and in
his words he was pursued by grace I
believe that everyone in this country
should have that opportunity to be
pursued by grace when Abigail was born
we thought it was gonna be this perfect
thing but she was really sick and she
couldn't swallow and she was in
intensive care and back then the
insurance companies had a rule and they
kicked me out of the hospital even
though she was in intensive care in 24
hours and a few months later I went to
the legislature worked with a number of
legislators and we passed one of the
first laws in the country
guaranteeing new moms and their babies a
48-hour hospital stay
[Applause]
[Music]
that's how I do my work and as my friend
Elizabeth note tonight
people told me just like they told her
that they didn't think a woman could be
elected in my case it was elected to the
US Senate no woman had ever done it
before but I came back I defied
expectations and I won and I and I have
done it over and over again in the
reddest of red districts and the bluest
of blue districts and when I got to the
US Senate people told me oh it's so hard
to get things done well in that gridlock
of Washington DC I have passed over 100
bills as a lead Democrat and tonight in
New Hampshire as everyone had counted us
out even a week ago thank you pundits I
came back and we delivered
[Music]
we have been on quite a journey together
and you've learned this about me I never
give up but my story is nothing compared
to the resilience that I've seen all
over this country the mom in California
her loss who lost her child to gun
violence and even through her grief and
heartbreak she has joined the fight to
keep our children safe the immigrant who
works two jobs and still struggles to
put food on the table but is determined
to raise her kids in America so that
they have a better future the farmer
who's facing bankruptcy because of bad
Trump policies but persists in working
the land just like his parents and his
grandparents before him America deserves
a president who doesn't give up or give
in just because a decision is hard
America deserves a president who is as
resilient as her people
[Applause]
America deserves a president who's going
to take on the challenges of our time
climate change and affordable education
and college immigration reform justice
and democracy and yes bringing down the
cost of health care our country cannot
take another four years of Donald Trump
the rules the rule of law can't
withstand another four years of a
president who thinks that he is above it
our collective sense of decency can't
handle another four years of a president
who doesn't care about it
our democracy can't tolerate another
four years of a president who wants to
bulldoze right through it and our
American Dream cannot tolerate a
president that thinks he can choose who
lives it the president might as well as
might as well have a sign on his desk
that says the buck stops anywhere but
here he literally he blames everyone he
blames think about this for anything
that goes wrong he blames Barack Obama
he blames the city of Baltimore he
blames the head of the Federal Reserve
that he appointed he blames the energy
secretary that he nominated he blames
the city of Baltimore he blames the
Kingdom of Denmark who does that and my
favorite recent one he blames the Prime
Minister of Canada for cutting him out
of the Canadian version of home alone -
that's what this guy does that is Donald
Trump I think we can do better because
for the people of this country when
things go wrong they don't have anyone
to blame they just have to pick
themselves up and I can promise you this
when I am behind that desk I will take
responsibility instead of passing it on
I will reach across the aisle and work
with Americans in good faith instead of
picking fights I will bring this country
together instead of tearing it apart
[Music]
some of you have heard the story about
Franklin Delano Roosevelt so he was
beloved and when he died they put his
body in a train and it went through the
countryside to Washington DC and people
would spontaneously stand next to those
rail tracks to show their respects and
the story goes that one guy was standing
there sobbing regular guy had his hat
across his chest and this reporter says
to him sir
did you know President Roosevelt you
mind me asking did you know him and the
guy says no I didn't know President
Roosevelt but he knew me he knew me
that is what's lacking right now in the
White House that empathy that ability of
a president to put himself or herself in
the show what is lacking is that sacred
trust between the people of this nation
and the President of the United States
and my friends I will restore that trust
[Music]
if you are having trouble whoa
if you are having trouble deciding
between boots coli prescription or
filling your refrigerator with food I
know you and I will fight for you if you
cannot decide how are you gonna stretch
that paycheck to pay for your rent or
pay your mortgage I know you and I will
fight for you right and if you are
having trouble deciding how are you
gonna pay for the childcare for your
kids and the long-term care for your
parents I know you and I will fight for
you if you want a Democratic nominee who
can make our tent bigger who can make
our coalition wider and our coattails
longer I know you and I will fight for
you if you feel stuck in the extremes of
our politics and you are tired of the
noise and the nonsense you have a home
with me if you want a nominee who can
stand up to Donald Trump on that debate
stage would you well no I can do I need
your votes yes and I'm going to need
those votes of the people in Nevada yes
and I'm going to need the votes in South
Carolina and beyond but most of all I
need your hearts I don't have that big
bank account I don't have that big name
of some of the other people that are in
this race and I am NOT a newcomer with
no political record but what I do is get
things done what I have is your back so
I ask you to join us at Amy Klobuchar
calm
[Applause]
thank you Thank You New Hampshire we are
on to Nevada because the best is yet to
come
[Applause]
okay I want to thank a few people before
we start the music oh yeah that rapture
uh who have been here with me in New
Hampshire from the very beginning and I
am so proud to have their help and
support it has meant the world first of
all my great state director scott mhairi
[Music]
[Applause]
and my campaign manager and our team
justin audio guy so we've just heard
from senator Klobuchar who is giving
somewhat of a victory speech this room
is electric right now I've covered
several election watch parties and I can
tell you this one has a lot of
enthusiasm the people here really are
supportive of this candidate and perhaps
surprised because she was not supposed
to make it this far in fact one of the
key words she kept saying in this speech
right now is resilience that she had
resilience all right so what's going on
Bernie Sanders lead has actually dropped
below two percent for the first time in
the evening now leading Pete Budaj edge
by only one point nine five so we're
watching that 71 percent of the vote is
in the lead has also gone below four
thousand votes and now going even a
little further beyond four thousand two
about thirty nine hundred or so the lead
now one point nine four dropping just
another hair so it continues to tighten
the question is will Bernie's lead keep
going at the point at which Budaj edge
runs out of votes with which he could
make up that gap so we are going to keep
watching that very very closely if
you're just joining us we have been
following the results we have seen
Elizabeth Warren give a speech we have
seen Joe Biden give a speech we have
heard a great part from Amy Klobuchar
here and soon soon I mean maybe by maybe
by 10:15 or 10:30 we should have a
clearer mathematical sense of whether
there are enough votes left
so to speak
to make up this difference if we have
200,000 votes right now with 71%
reporting at a certain point if the lead
doesn't get smaller it will just become
very unlikely that Pete Budaj edge would
be able to take over that lead from
Bernie Sanders but we are going to keep
watching welcome if you're watching on
twitch make sure to follow my twitch
channel I want to say thanks to wax
matches for the prime sub with the
message she's so boring dem zero cool
says David why does CNN seem more
critical of Bernie even a little anti
Bernie like with the question about him
being sexist at the debate yes I mean
listen these corporate channels are
establishment MSNBC CNN you know Fox
News will sometimes throw Bernie a bone
to be contrarian because it's a
right-wing net wing network but they
therefore of maintaining the status quo
essentially if you're just joining us on
YouTube please make sure to hit the like
button we are just a hair away from
3,000 likes on the stream the likes
really help the stream and I also am
asking you with peace and love and total
humility to hit the subscribe button
there's nearly 4000 of you here and we
are just about 375 subscribers away from
eight hundred and five thousand so
please do hit hit that like button and
then smash that subscribe button let me
say thank you to a couple of people
anthony Licata is new member number 43
of the evening Tracy curry is new member
number 44
Tracy curry actually signing up twice I
guess we'll count it twice she is now
new member number 45 as well jhonny
stowaway is new member number 46
Lindsey Craig is new member number 47
thank you so much we are three new
members away from our goal of 50 let's
get caught up on some super chats a
quick update the lead again shrinking
just a bit for Bernie Sanders now down
to 1.9 no way what is this this is 1.9
burn baby Buddha judge well
Oh point nine two or one point nine
three or so so this is this is as small
as the lead has been for for the entire
evening mr. app B says why do corporate
Democrats bash Trump so much publicly
and claim to want to beat them yet when
in reality they have the same agenda to
benefit the rich and wealthy end goal is
the same why fight they fight for their
party that's it that's it quite simply
name withheld says pony-soldiers since
1942 Sam here says any funny business
from the DNC again just got on nothing
in particular tonight I mean the leads
been tightening for for Bernie as more
and more votes have been counted
Trent tanner says Trump has the same
take as you do on warrants peached
check out his Twitter all right let's
check out Donald Trump's Twitter real
quick this was polling let's see what
Donald Trump has tweeted uh let's see
here a lot of nuns and Elizabeth Warren
sometimes referred to as Pocahontas is
having a really bad night I think she's
sending signals that she wants out
calling for new unity is her way of
getting there going home and having a
nice cold beer with her husband I
actually agree with this let's let's do
a retweet
oh I'm not logged in okay that's why my
settings aren't yeah okay very good well
I guess we can't do that okay that was
Trump's take and it is similar to mine
for sure
Bernie's lead growing a little bit to
2.0 for the lead stretching to forty two
hundred votes again we are getting to
the point where this will become an
insurmountable lead for Bernie Sanders
but very likely they will come away from
New Hampshire with the same number of
Delegates
let's see obviously I don't agree by the
way okay let me clarify I don't agree
with Donald Trump referring to her as
Pocahontas obviously I do believe that
calling for unity and her entire speech
were a signal that she is sort of
conceding the entire thing that is the
impression that I get I don't agree with
the horribly racist nickname of her
Pocahontas
to be completely and totally clear
burly gonna go sends a super chat serial
famine says you and destiny Steven
Kenneth destiny bonel ii are my favorite
commentators in 2020 thank you very much
I appreciate that
was up my homies says man's meat whoops
hold on a second man mens meat 2020 okay
sheev Palpatine says is Joe Biden
suffering from cognitive decline affirm
maybe Waller is me asks do you think
Clos Bashar's strength is poking holes
in other candidates positions she seems
to me to not stand alone well does that
make sense yeah I I agree she's had some
good moments in debates but when you
just see her speak by herself she
doesn't to me at least inspire very much
of anything
Justin DPS asks are we heading for a
contested convention too early to tell I
think we'll have a better sense of that
after March 3rd Super Tuesday
Mike K Biden gaffe
he said men's meet not ends meet oh I
didn't notice that
Joseph van Scoy says Oh something very
weird just happened actually let's see
what's going on here oh there we go okay
some of some of my I just looked for a
second like we completely lost the
entire stream I am very very glad that
we did not that would have been very
scary I thought for a second that we did
lose the stream can you imagine if we
lost the stream at a critical moment in
this evening
Joseph van Scoy says I guess the
groundhog saw its shadow four more
months of Clos Bashar's she is going to
be around for a bit for sure
Gregory shavers jr. says let's get some
phone calls David open the lines we'll
see we may do that X says David
listening to Amy is becoming torturous I
apologize I didn't mean to torture
anybody ask I rwb why says she has the
charisma of a black hole it takes the
life right out of you
Chris Carbajal says if yang dropped out
yeah
where do you think vote go yang dropped
out today and his vote is very small I
don't think it'll make a huge difference
Skye bucks says you won the Raj Royale
was amazing please do it again I had a
great time I had a great time and if you
did not see it make sure to check me out
on the raj Royale this was from Saturday
we started with 12 we whittled down to
just two two opponents it was me against
airsoft fattie that's the name of this
gentleman at the bottom here and I think
he's just great I think he is genuinely
one of the greatest contemporary
entertainers in the United States and I
encourage you to check out his channel
and check out everything that he has
going on it was really a great time we
are now at 73 almost 74 percent
reporting and again the Bernie lead is
shrinking in terms of percentage it is
down to one point eight nine as small as
it has been all night and it is almost
exactly a four thousand vote margin for
Bernie now even if percentage-wise the
lead keeps shrinking if it remains at
four thousand votes
it will soon be difficult for Pete to
overtake it I think if we get to 80 or
85 percent reporting and the margin is
still 4,000 its unless there is a very
lopsided vote still to come in it's
going to be it's going to be difficult
to overtake that one point nine seven
percent lead now with the latest update
and the lead pushing up to about 4200
votes so we are continuing to track that
let me say thank you to Philip Hecht who
is new member number 48 of the evening
our goal tonight is 50 members I believe
that we can do it we are only two away
and the coupon code 2020 now will save
you 66 percent believe it or not let's
see here David Adams asks did you see
Trump's glitch at his New Hampshire
rally I did not
Walter Newberry says
why isn't Bernie trending anywhere check
Twitter I don't know I don't I don't
know much about that I'm not sure max
says more David + destiny content please
I may be doing things with destiny
upcoming we are keeping an eye this is
video from the Bernie Sanders campaign
HQ or event location this is also video
from looks like about 40 feet away at
the same Bernie Sanders location we are
also keeping an eye on the vote totals
as we are now approaching 75 percent
reporting with a one point 98% gap
between Bernie Sanders and Pete Budaj
very very close but the margin in terms
of raw votes remains at about 4200
welcome if you're joining me on Twitch
we do have a solid audience of nearly a
thousand on Twitch and I want to say hi
and welcome to everybody there we
recently heard from wax matches who
grabbed the twitch Prime subscription
gamer legend and odd shaman set some
bits which are very much appreciated and
yeah we got a big boost on twitch over
the weekend when I appeared on the Rajoy
al and took it down I took down a
victory there by quite frankly in the
last voting round I believe it was 55 to
45 I defeated my the last contender and
that a lot a lot of action happening on
Twitch and of course if you are watching
on twitch I invite you to grab a twitch
subscription twitch prime regular twitch
whatever whatever pleases you we are
awaiting now on the next update we will
probably get to 75% reporting and we I I
believe that soon we are going to be
able to make a projection
although networks may continue to wait
if we get another five percentage points
of the vote and the lead remains
somewhere between four thousand and
forty forty three hundred forty five
hundred it's going to become really
difficult for Pete Budaj edge to make it
up and we we should know that I
think in the next 15 to 20 minutes let's
see these four people wandering these
are the results on box these are the
results from Vox some people concerned
that there are more results elsewhere
these these are the results we have my
friends so we're going with it let me
say thank you to William Navedo Sapp at
Cepeda who is new member number 49 let's
do something new member number 50 I'll
send you a free item from the David
Pakman show online store at david
pakman.com slash gear anything you want
t-shirt the black coffee mug which is
the most popular item we're just one
member away from 50 we filled the bar
all the way up join pakman.com is the
place to sign up number 50 I'll get you
an item on me and it will be I I you
will love it you will absolutely love it
ok with the next update the lead for
Bernie has extended a little bit more
percentage-wise
we're at one point nine seven but in
terms of the raw vote totals again it is
it's up to a just a hair over 4200 and
we are very close to 75 percent of the
vote being counted let me say thanks to
sand boxer for subscribing with twitch
prime who says phone calls will help
with twitch in general spob subscribed
to twitch prime says David please
include the percentage reporting on our
screen thanks babe let me see if I can
get it on screen without losing anything
I might have to zoom out is the only
issue that's my concern let's see if I
do one zoom out there we go and then if
I go down there we go
all right percentage reporting now at
the bottom of the screen I hope that
that is better seventy four point four
one percent reporting you can see it
down here still waiting on 76 different
precincts to report
are we good I think we're good it looks
like maybe Bernie Sanders is expected to
speak soon does anybody know it looks
like there's a lot
action which could be a Gluck's break
for my Bloomberg who's waiting in the
wind but also Bernie Sanders no ok
nothing yet
so we'll keep an eye on these vote
totals as they continue to come in 221
precincts reporting as of right now
let me say thanks to Amber Rose for the
YouTube subscription thanks amber very
much appreciate that we don't know so
remember back into sap 2016 the New
Hampshire Democratic primary was called
at 8:00 p.m. Eastern
it was immediately called when all the
polls closed Bernie Sanders winning
62-38 over Hillary Clinton much tighter
this year because we have multiple
candidates there are three candidates
over 10% there are another two right
around 10 percent and the significantly
tighter race and the results do now seem
to be slowing down Duval Patrick is the
former Massachusetts governor eight
hundred and fifty eight votes Michael
Bennett and Andrew yang have both
dropped out tonight so basically if you
look from here down two of those three
people have dropped out if you look from
here down including Tulsi all of these
people should drop out the only reason I
say Tom Styer can justify staying in is
that he's been pouring money into South
Carolina and he's actually in second
place there based on a poll from a week
ago he may actually end up getting
delegates in South Carolina and thus I
think it's reasonable for for him to
stay in at this point in time although
you know how much beyond that Super
Tuesday I don't know I do expect oh by
the way Michael Bloomberg not here
because Michael Bloomberg just skipped
Iowa and New Hampshire Michael Bloomberg
going essentially right to Super Tuesday
if you're watching on Twitch we have a
hypetrain
opportunity we failed hugely with the
last hypetrain it was embarrassing I
almost had to cancel everything I almost
had to cancel myself because it went so
poorly but we do have a hypetrain
opportunity over on Twitch and I say
thank you to I promise
for subscribing with prime and we do
have a scam train as many people like to
refer to
two more precincts have just reported we
are now up to 223 precincts the lead has
shrunk again to one point nine five on a
percentage basis but it stays about 4200
votes still about 4200 votes separating
Bernie and Pete Budaj
okay let's do the free item from the
David Pakman show store new member
number 50 of this evening is Chuck Cole
Chuck Cole is new member number 50 I
also want to say thank you to Juan
Carlos Ordonez who is new member number
51 of the evening I also want to say
thanks to Tim and Holm who is new member
number 52 of the evening Denver Minik is
new member number 53 Trudi Willowby is
new member number 54 and Martin Campbell
is new member number 55
thank you so much to everybody who has
who has signed up very very much
appreciate it we are now with 225
precincts reporting we are continuing to
see Bernie's lead is 4200 almost on the
dot 40202 right now that percentage lead
keeps shrinking now it's 1.9 but no
staying at one point nine three and if
Pete Budaj edge cannot make up vote
totals remember he can keep closing in
in terms of percentage Pete's got to
make up votes if he wants a shot at this
thing
Amy is essentially out she's almost
9,000 votes behind Pete I want to say I
mean it's interesting whether Bernie or
Pete win but to be very clear they're
gonna end up with basically the same
number of Delegates at this point it may
vary by one I can't think of the last
time a nomination depended on one
delegate so that this is not gonna
significantly move the needle in terms
of who we expect who we ultimately
to win you're joining us on YouTube and
you have any questions comments I would
love to hear via super chat super chats
pop up on the screen on the right who do
you think will drop out and when okay so
structure your messages in this way I
believe
for example Biden will drop out after
South Carolina or I believe Tulsi will
drop out after Nevada or whatever I do
want to hear from folks if you are
considering sending a super chat
of course any question is welcome and I
will answer all questions but that is
something I would be interested in
hearing from folks about meanwhile over
on Twitch we are now with four minutes
to go trying to complete compete a level
three hype train which would be huge I
don't think we've gotten past level two
in a while over over on Twitch we have a
two hundred and twenty-fifth precinct
reporting and Bernie's lead has actually
grown it is now just a hair under forty
three hundred votes and the percentage
difference is 1.96 Bernie Sanders again
just creeping up the vote lead with a
number of the recent precincts and I see
someone in the chat saying Bernie had a
hundred and fifty two thousand votes in
2016 we can actually check that very
quickly indeed Bernie had 152 in 2016
now what is interesting about these
results and I don't want to say that
this is good or bad for the progressive
movement the progressive vote totals
right now are 77,000 meaning if you add
Bernie's 56 four and Warren's 25 that is
that is almost on the dot seventy seven
thousand votes total that is about half
of what Bernie got and so you know of
course this is a very different race
many more candidates that is just one
sort of analysis that we can look at you
could argue I see people in the chat
saying steyr is also a progressive you
could add his votes that would get us to
about 85,000 so these are the types of
analyses that we'll be able to do
tomorrow more of more than likely okay
over via super chat Matt shava says if
Bernie adopted universal basic income he
would be the 46th tonight okay Keshav
Jaganath says des speed and Klobuchar
arts performance tonight helped Sanders
in the long run their momentum could eat
Bloomberg's support on Super Tuesday in
my opinion I really don't know yet I'm
gonna have to think about that I guess I
I don't know that I agree with that
analysis but I'll talk about that a
little bit tomorrow with a 220 6th
precinct reporting the lead for Bernie
Sanders stays about 4,300 votes we are
really getting down to the wire in pete
being able to even conceivably make up
that vote difference rock lee says if
you click on the vox map it shows pete's
strongest County is 100% counted Bernie
will rise and finish around 29% Pete
still has no path to the nomination
let's take a look at that we do have
some of those numbers I believe here
let's take a look so when we look at
Pete Budaj edge Pete let's see
72 percent twenty six point eight for
Pete 27:31 25 25 25 so this is Pete's
strongest down here and it says 70
percent reporting yeah I just don't know
that I see the numbers exactly the way
you're pointing it out although maybe
I'm misunderstanding to me it looks like
Pete's strongest County Cheshire County
by percentage Oh what am I talking about
that's Bernie Sanders I'm an idiot what
on earth am I talking about so Pete 26.8
Pete 24.8 p25 9 P 24 right so Pete's
strongest is Rockingham and this says
it's only 66 percent counted so in any
case
continue to watch it and we will see we
are standing by now at the Pete Buddha
edge headquarters potentially for some
kind of a speech from Mayor Pete and
waiting with 226 precincts reporting
right now okay so we are caught up over
there let me say thank you to Alina and
yet
Alina a nyet is new member number 56 of
the evening and Steve gray is new member
number 57 of the evening
[Music]
kabuki boo fan 1 and 18 said or no sorry
Brody Andrew Mulligan says top three
policies to combat voter suppression
nonpartisan redistricting same-day voter
registration and voter purges are
illegal I don't know I'd have to think
about it there's actually probably more
than three that you need kabuki fan one
in 18 says check the chart below the map
sort by County okay chart below the map
sort by County uh sort by County okay ah
okay Pete Buddha judge one hundred
percent reporting I see so the place
that's 100 percent reporting is a strong
Budaj okay I see what you're saying very
very interesting yeah yeah we'll have to
see remember that the counties are also
different sizes and that is also that is
also a factor we just got a couple more
precincts Bernie's lead still 4200 that
lead is staying it is not changing
Bernie with a solid 4200 vote lead
Sam Dean says g'day which candidate do
you think could communicate with foreign
countries to help reestablish a sense of
trust in America and repair trade
arguments almost any of them is going to
be able to repair some of the damage
done by Donald Trump
Rock Lee says I was using the map below
the chart you're using now right we
figured that out lock metal says
Bloomberg more like doom Berg am i right
LOL very clever very very clever I like
what you did there
we are expecting we are actually past
75% reporting at this point and we are
now heading to 80% expecting possibly
Pete Buddha judge to speak soon maybe
Bernie Sanders I I think that at this
point we know how these results are
ultimately going to go Bernie and Pete
are going to end up with almost
certainly the same number of Delegates
tonight they are neck and neck in terms
of the percentage Bernie ahead by about
forty to forty about forty to fifty
right now forty to eighty and almost
certainly they will end up with the same
number of Delegates out of New Hampshire
which will keep them roughly tied to
getting into Nevada that that's it's
very hard to imagine it changing
drastically at this point in time and if
anybody disagrees with me I would love
to hear from you thanks for all the
different bits over on twitch Medici and
veggie-boy and jh8 CS anonymous cheerer
pia pom and a whole bunch of other
different people very much appreciate
that the peat crowd is starting to get
fired up I wonder if they are expecting
Pete Buddha judge to come out sometime
soon
if you have any questions or comments as
we are continuing to track results two
ways to do it if you're watching on
youtube send a super chat they'll pop up
on the lower left of the screen as you
can see if you are on Twitch you can
send a message with a twitch Prime or
twitch regular twitch subscription and
the message will pop up with your
subscription in the blue rectangle in
the upper right gregory shavers jr. says
how about those phone lines David
ring-ring
Rock Lee says Warren will drop after
South Carolina or Super Tuesday at best
Pete will outlast her with money
propping him up
but will endure several losses in March
through May all right very specific
prediction okay let's do a little bit of
phone lines if people want to call and I
will take some calls now because later
we are going to be in the thick of the
results so let's get set up
you can call in at six one seven eight
three zero forty seven fifty I'll take a
few calls now I will keep going to super
chats and twitch messages and all of
that stuff Tommy Adam says have you seen
the airsoft Fatih YouTube documentary I
have not seen that but it sounds very
interesting
let's get connected six one seven thank
you for calling in to the David Pakman
show please do not use speakerphone have
your question ready and listen for David
to call out your area code right six one
seven eight three zero forty seven fifty
is the number let me get myself all
connected first as you can see Bernie
Sanders lead actually growing now to
almost 5,000 votes Bernie growing let's
just to do it because we haven't heard
from him for a while let's go right to
Jimmy from Philly Jimmy from Philly
regular LSD user no longer drinking
Jimmy what's new with you Jimmy you're
on I can hear you breathing Jimmy from
Philly you are on Jimmy I hear you
breathing I don't know what you're doing
almost sounded like maybe Jimmy from
Philly lost his voice or something like
that that's very interesting I don't
know what's going on there
okay Oh weird I got disconnected now
from my own phone system that's weird
let me call back in it's strange Jimmy
from Philly's still on let's see somehow
I'm not Jimmy from Philly a state has
taken over the phone system he's on and
I'm not
thank you for calling in to the David
Pakman show
please do not use speakerphone have your
question ready and listen for David to
call out your area code right all right
let's see here okay Jimmy from Philly
can you hear me yeah what's up David hey
what's going on Jimmy
hi now here's my question right yeah
okay
so in 2016 basically Bernie was cheated
by a chick
Hillary Clinton is heard any times
around it supports he turns around and
supports to check that cheated him right
now he neck-and-neck with a homosexual
what makes you think he can stand up the
Donald Trump if he couldn't beat a woman
and he's neck and neck with a homosexual
that had no name before this any
interest I didn't know who blew the
check was what has any of you think that
Bernie Bernie could stand up there Trump
I just don't understand how is Pete's
sexual orientation relevant how is it
relevant
how are you kidding me know how
transsexual you would say the same thing
David that's funny that's right I would
say he would begin the numbers you got
right now oh you think the day is
helping Pete actually wondering how I
think Bernie being a socialist to top
Birdman Bernie's not a socialist in Iowa
Pete's being helped by being gay I think
so
did you see that a voter once he found
Joe gay retracted to Democratic Party
okay it's a Democratic Party it states
your way I mean that next time will be a
training for president use a lot
insensitive term Jimmy we don't use that
term that's it that's it is it
Oh transaction was better no I don't
think so Oh
what should I say yeah one of the 58
Facebook genders and we you know I know
Jimmy I don't know I don't have to be
sensitive to these people David Jimmy
you called in once I don't have to be
sure to hold on a second Jimmy Jimmy
you're shot out of a cannon tonight can
I get a word in here yeah okay you once
called in and you talked about how it
was a tragic story but you were
separated from a family member that's
important to you because of alleged
violence that you committed now wouldn't
it be insensitive for someone called in
and started calling you an abuser and
using even uglier language wouldn't
wouldn't that be sort of insensitive
David that would be a false accusation
that wouldn't be insensitive
the police certainly didn't think really
judge is a homosexual I am making a
clear statement about his own admitted
sexuality but I am NOT making with the
mall claiming wrong with being gay but I
didn't I didn't say that there was so
then what are we even talking about
buttburn can't beat a woman he's not
connect with a homo what makes you think
he could stand up the Donald Trump gonna
happen the way the way you're talking
about Pete's sexual orientation it
sounds like you do think there's
something wrong with it where you think
it is less than something else yes okay
laughter the man so what generally is
what gender is Pete he's riding a pony
pony Oh Jamie we're done all right very
good
Jimmy's out let's go next to our caller
from the three one three area code it
just again you know we tolerate it for a
little while but when you're just being
disrespectful there's no place for that
here okay three one three you're on I
apologize that you had to sit through
that three one three is it me yes it is
oh yeah it's all good um I've heard them
useful silly uh even I roll tonight yeah
but what's that being said with all the
Caucasian states
sorry what'd you say did you work Asian
states
yeah basically the white face okay all
right
and then with you know with the actual
states that was that has
african-american voters Latino voters is
you know this is a demographic that
actually is represented that's
representing the Democratic Party right
I'm just curious on how like the
delegate the delegate maps the
delegation mass is going to be when it
comes alike Nevada South Carolina and
then up Super Tuesday because I'm really
curious on how the ordering is gonna be
with because more than likely Barney's
probably not going to win Nevada he's
probably not gonna win South Carolina
correct but I'm curious on the
delegation or when it comes when he
chooses Super Tuesday and with the other
candidates this is why I don't believe
we are really going to know anything
about who is in this for the long haul
until after Super Tuesday because
between now and March 3rd you're gonna
have a bunch of different candidates
pick up a few delegates in what are
small states only at Super Tuesday
are we actually going to get a sense so
I just don't know the answer yet but
certainly Iowa and New Hampshire are not
demographically representative of the
rest of the country yeah yeah that's a
cool Cajun thing was this a joke yeah no
but one quick one quick question because
I know you have a lot of colors I'm
thinking that what probably will
probably happen is if Biden win South
Carolina and maybe Tom Stein Tom I
forgot what time whatever time black
name is once Nevada yes
did you do you think this would be a
scenario where Bernie will only need one
like thirty percent of the votes of each
state just to get to necessarily
delegate to take the lead I have one the
others exact scenario I'd have to run
the numbers to see if that's realistic
or possible and by the way the diversity
shot it'd be on it at be at winning
South Carolina but not Nevada I don't
know if you misspoke there uh no well I
still think mine was gonna win I mean is
this I got my
people live in South Carolina and I just
understand but they support a buying
hell I was in Detroit and in my my my
people were talking about this Biden and
like the younger generation was talking
about Bernie it was it really was like a
true generational divide yeah like this
the older voters said why is Bernie
yelling at me and then the younger rows
like well why are you not supporting
policy I think it's very very very hard
right now it's absolutely crazy what's
going on listen thank you for the call I
am gonna move on we will keep in touch
and see if that scenario plays out let
me say thank you to sunny 1984 for the
twitch Prime subscription let me say
thanks to ani on line one for the twitch
Prime subscription very much appreciate
that I also want to thank a couple of
new members at least one David and Ben
Salkin are new members new member I
guess number 58 and Steve gray is new
member number 59 thanks to both of you
very much appreciate that the new goal
100 members we are now with 236
precincts reporting seeing a 4,800 vote
lead for Bernie Sanders Bernie has
expanded his lead and I believe soon
Bernie's lead will be insurmountable we
will see if I am correct lock metal says
the Overton Window is a hell of a drug
and ali reza murga semi says hi David if
Sanders becomes president how likely do
you think Tulsi becomes Secretary of
State since he's mostly into foreign
policy do you think she is a fit for the
position or not no I hope that that does
not happen let's hope that that does not
happen I would not like to see that
let's go next to our caller from the
three one five area code who's calling
from three one five today hello let me
yes it is yes it is hey this is Jim and
I'm not a homophobe okay good good start
I was actually just curious on what you
think about Bloomberg's chances right
now it looks like he's doing
exceptionally well in Texas in Florida
here's the thing yeah
all right I was just saying if you
thought there was a clear path to
victory there I don't see if I might be
told my parents yeah mm-hmm oh yeah both
of my parents are staunch Blumberg
supporters and I showed them that clip
this morning of him talking about you
know I'm sure you saw that clip of him
this morning of course I think about
found that in subtitle they didn't put
it out well yeah yeah yeah well they
just blinked at it and didn't even care
because they think that his climate
proposal you know what he what he's done
for the climate is so good and he's a
businessman and they just sit down and
watch MSNBC all day right so here's the
deal yeah yeah yeah oh yeah Bloomberg
let me let me I'll give you my sense of
it I believe Bloomberg may end up third
or fourth in delegates by the time it's
all said and done by the way when you
say Bloomberg's climate thing I don't
know of a thing Bloomberg has done for
the climate I'm interested in hearing
more about that I don't know oh yeah no
no else but like yeah
these days continue with the Politico -
oh happy win from the country oh boy
I gotcha listen I'm going to answer the
rest of the question offline I do
appreciate the call Bloomberg is pouring
money into Super Tuesday States I
believe Bloomberg is going to pull
delegates out of Super Tuesday I believe
Bloomberg may have a big role to play
and denying Bernie the nomination on the
first ballot at the convention I've said
it before this is not an endorsement of
Bloomberg I'm not voting for Bloomberg
or anything like that thank you very
very much let me say thank you to a
baron Steuben who says via super chat
feel the Bern I also want to say thanks
to old Ben for subscribing with twitch
prime we are still at 236 precincts
reporting the reports are slowing down I
don't know if you find folks have
noticed but the precinct reports have
been slowing down more and more and more
let me say thank you to a really
terrific person Paul Clemente Paul
Clemente is new member number 60 boom 60
of the evening at join pakman.com I
invite you to
use the coupon code 2020 now at join
pakman.com grab a two-thirds discount
with the coupon code 2020 now very very
exciting number happening there
let's go next we are taking calls at 6 1
7 8 3 0 47 50 people wondering there are
27 people holding just to give you a
sense of the phone lines let's go - I
don't fully understand this it's been
almost a year since we heard from them
amber and her boyfriend at 8 to 8 amber
and her boyfriend what's going on
hey it's just her boyfriend today her
husband now
oh wow her husband now a lot has
happened in the last 10 months oh yeah I
just want to say this is my first time
calling I'm a big fan I listen to show
every day I've been a member for over
two years
thanking us keep up the great work
my question is with Pete Buddha judge
doing so well compared to Joe Biden
right would if Pete Budaj was the
eventual nominee would that be better
for us then if it was debating or
nursing him I actually would have to
think about that because I recently was
asked would I vote for steyr Biden or
Buddha judge and I said I would
definitely vote for steyr I don't care
about star being a billionaire stires
better on climate steyr is I believe
more progressive okay between Buddha
judge and Biden Buddha judge is better
on some policies but I actually the one
thing about Biden is he is a diplomat
and I know a lot of people say he's
older and slowing down and all this
different stuff Pete has no experience
and I know some people don't care about
experience Biden actually has important
relationships with world leaders if you
put a gun to my head and say do you vote
Buddha edge or Biden I would have to
think about it actually oh okay I'm not
supporting either to be clear yes I
understand burning all the way Bernie
2020 thank you all right thank you
Amber's now husband died
the phone call says e Canales this oh
wait no sorry I skipped Shannon Shannon
Bennett says will Sanders pick up the
majority of Yang's love I don't know
that we will wait and see
says he Canal has been a while since
I've heard from you ceci says he says
hey David you're still great I may not
agree with you 100% of the time but I
thank you for all you do with peace and
love thank you rich chase says do you
think that due to the Iowa Fiasco the
Democratic Party is making sure to be
way above board about the result in New
Hampshire I don't know that's a good
question I'm not I'm not sure about that
Elizabeth no foul play so far that I'm
aware of let me put it that way although
we are all of a sudden stuck at 236
precincts and we don't know why
maybe I'll just do a hard refresh just
to see if that's still what's going on
yeah it is interesting
still at 32 36 Elizabeth Smith says
David I'll buy a DP gift for number 65
oh okay we have an offer from Elizabeth
Smith Elizabeth Smith says that for new
member number 65 at join pakman.com she
will buy you a gift from the David
Pakman show online store at join
pakman.com I like that I think that
that's a that's a great idea thank you
so much Elizabeth we will coordinate if
and when we get to new member number 65
let's go next to our caller from the 207
area code 207 is that Maine if I recall
correctly that it correct
who's this there's a Jake hey Jake
what's up hey David I just had a quick
question about a ha and we'll seen a lot
of the pundits from the mainstream media
like all the places talk about how
Bernie really has to bring out the young
vote cuz he has no chance with the rest
of us you know people so like and
they're saying that he's not doing that
and because of that they think he can't
win I just wanna know what your thoughts
on that I completely reject that on
principle yeah that's how I feel
they're really pushing that narrative
real hard don't let them I mean just you
know vote for the person who's who you
agree with on policy ignore all that
other stuff it's just noise right now
yeah
that's you know Bernie's my go-to guy so
far but I mean I believe in his policies
more than anyone else for sure then you
know who you're voting for alright thank
you David that ball
all right Jake great to hear from you
folks we do have news and it is actually
pretty pretty stunning news with the
latest update out of New Hampshire
Bernie Sanders lead has dropped below 1%
in New Hampshire it is now at point 9 6
% and it is actually no now now it is
back up now it is back up to 1.6 percent
for a moment there the lead dropped to
only two thousand votes the lead is now
back up to the same forty two hundred
votes so for a moment there Bernie's
lead got down to only two thousand votes
but it is indeed back up let's go to our
caller from the six one seven area code
may be a local caller here in the Boston
area six one seven are either six one
seven going twice six one seven you're
on if you have us muted please unmute
because you are on live and this is the
last opportunity all right six one seven
is gone let's go next to our caller from
the eight four three area code who's
calling today from 843 I was not able to
hear who this is you said something
about the YouTube chat yeah I said this
is t haze I'm one of the mods in the
YouTube chat oh thank you I appreciate
your service
yes but anyways um so I've been going
over the numbers and outstanding votes
and I I think it's a pretty safe bet to
say that Bernie will probably when um
Pete just doesn't have the outstanding
votes in the areas he needs yeah we're
over 80% now
the lead is still now it's 3,800 votes
so unless it shrinks to I I think that
Pete needs to get tell me if you agree
if Pete doesn't get to within 2,000
votes by the time they're at 85 percent
I think it's probably done I agree with
you I already I already think it's safe
to call but your uh your situation I
definitely agree with that yeah um I'm
really surprised that Budaj as you know
did as well as he did but I mean with
the media letting him declare victory
for a week and all the all the all the
you know he was on TV for a week
declaring victory so I mean they kind of
prop them up and it's kind of
disappointing yeah no doubt but um it
looks like and you know here's the thing
it almost doesn't matter in a sense
it'll matter for headlines but Pete and
Bernie tonight are ending up with the
same number of Delegates in all
likelihood mm-hmm yeah one thing I do
want to say is you can take this to the
bank I think that Pete when it gets to
Nevada and South Carolina Pete's gonna
just fall off that man Michael Bloomberg
Michael boom Bloomberg would end up
being propped up by his money and the
media and in about I'd say three weeks
maybe four weeks Michael Bloomberg's
gonna take over and I think it's gonna
be Bernie in Michael Bloomberg if I had
to put money on it that is well
according to their betting Mariana if
you look at the betting markets that is
actually what a lot of people are saying
Bernie's the most likely followed by
Bloomberg to be the nominees it's
interesting that you believe the same
yeah that's what I was basing off of
predicted and basing off the polls and
stuff I definitely think that's the most
likely scenario yep well we will see we
will soon know I think Bloomberg's gonna
do better than a lot of people think for
sure I I definitely agree especially
with the media and just it's crazy that
a billionaire can literally um you buy
his way into the election I mean it's
just ridiculous no doubt appreciatively
then I have a lot of people yep all
right take care let me say thanks to a
couple of other new members I want to
say thank you to Michael Havel who is
new member numbers
sixty-one I also want to say thanks to
Dominique Thornton who is new member
number 62 thank you so much remember
there is still an offer for a free item
from the David Pakman show store for a
new member number 65 Elizabeth Smith has
very kindly offered to get whoever is
new member number 65 at join pakman.com
a free item from david pakman.com slash
gear it looks like they are warming up
the audience for pood edge edge so we
will go to that at some point relatively
soon
looking at the vote totals we see that
it is thirty eight hundred votes
currently separating Bernard Sanders
from Peter Budaj edge a Brian Lane asks
how much will a warren dropout help
Bernie it'll help him but remember only
35% I believe of her support would go to
Bernie the other 65% would go to other
candidates so it may not help as much as
some people think let's go next to our
caller from the 732 area code who's
calling today from 732 hey what's going
on man hey what's up I'm still paying
for sabotage ago I just had a couple
questions hat what is um Bernie have to
do in Nevada to end the fear of a
contested convention what has to happen
in Nevada yeah there's nothing that
could happen in Nevada that would
drastically alter the possibility of a
contested convention it's it's too few
delegates to make a real difference okay
yeah um and my other question was what
do you think about stove efface and this
this poison that he's feeding me sorry
who
they'll be faith he's everywhere on the
news these days stow be face I you're
gonna have to enlighten me who's that
it's just it's just I just everywhere I
don't even I'm just trying to do things
that would make me smile of you this is
an adult or a child you're referring to
that will be he's a child oh okay I
don't want to talk about kids on the
stream so I we're gonna we're gonna move
oh he's leading yeah
okay very good you're off let's see mr.
Daughtry says I signed up for ACA and
unenrolled when I got employer insurance
the federal government did not register
my disenrollment and charge fees for two
years of ACA tax time why will Medicare
for all function better I don't know the
specifics of that situation but with
Medicare for all there's none of that
stuff there's no this type of insurance
versus that type of insurance do you get
it through work or not there's no more
employer-based insurance and it's a
completely different system we have a
couple more precincts reporting and we
now have a lead of four three four eight
for Bernie Sanders all but completely
insurmountable lead at this point in
time I am almost ready and I'm just
eyeballing this thing folks I am almost
ready to call it four Bernard Sanders
over Peter Budaj edge we may see Budaj
edge soon it looks like somebody was
warming up the crowd for him at his
event there I want to say a couple of
other thank-yous including a really
important one to Michael Kretchmer
Michael Kretchmer is the latest member
as Pete Budaj edge is coming out to
speak let's take a listen to former
mayor Pete who will no doubt in a
defiant and principled way claim victory
despite the fact that he has lost
thank you so much
[Applause]
one more time for our phenomenal New
Hampshire State co-chairs thank you for
your leadership and thank you for your
commitment
[Applause]
and we're gonna stick with just so I'm
gonna drop the phone lines for now just
for people's taste
[Applause]
I want to congratulate my competitors
and their supporters on their campaigns
here in New Hampshire you don't need to
clap it out
I admired senator Sanders when I was a
high school student I respect him
greatly to this day and I congratulate
him on his strong showing tonight is
that a dig at Bernie's Eve and I want to
congratulate senator Clovis our senator
Warren Vice President Biden and all of
our Democratic candidates and supporters
right and I know that we all share the
spirit that we heard from some of our
volunteers at a poll site earlier today
who welcomed a competing candidate with
chance of vote blued no matter who we
are on the same team unity the field
[Applause]
now over the past year some two dozen
campaigns have crisscross this state
each laying claim to the ability to
bring people together turn out the vote
and move Americans toward a brighter
future that too
and here in a state that goes by the
motto live free or die you made up your
own minds
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you asserted that famous independent
streak and thanks to you a campaign that
some said shouldn't be here at all has
shown that we are here to stay
[Applause]
were they hitting president
so many of you so many of you turned out
diehard Democrats independence unwilling
to stay on the side on the sidelines and
even some new leaf former Republicans
ready to vote for something they're
ready to vote for a politics defined by
how many we call in instead of by who we
push out so many of you chose to meet a
new era of challenge with a new
generation of leadership
so many of you decided hey guys is it
possible Trump's watching my stream he
tweeted exactly what I said about
Warren's speech and now he tweeted Pete
Buddha jej actually spelling it out
Buddha jej the way I've been saying it
is it possible possible now our campaign
moves on to Nevada to South Carolina the
communities across our country
and we will welcome new allies to our
movement at every step
[Applause]
we will go forward thanks to the work of
our extraordinary team of staff and
organizers and volunteers I may be
biased on this but I'm also right we
have the finest team in politics today
hey guys what hell just happen to the
results all of a sudden Pete Budaj what
the heck
Bernie's name is just gone anybody else
seeing this Bernie's name just
disappeared from this thing what what is
going on here let me refresh oh and they
have called it for Bernie Sanders that
is what is going on the race has been
called Bernie Sanders is the winner
today calling it right about when I
would have right at the 83 percent mark
with a 4400 vote lead Bernie Sanders
wing there it is thank you and we know
that team stretches across the country
we go forward fueled by hundreds of
thousands of grassroots supporters from
the woman in Minnesota who donated in
honor of the wife she lost to lung
cancer to the veteran from Connecticut
who sent $19 and 68 cents in honor of
the year that he served in Vietnam this
campaign belongs to them
[Applause]
and if our campaign moves you I hope
you'll go to Pete for america.com and
chip in whatever you can right and we go
forward knowing that this is our chance
our only chance not just to end the era
of Donald Trump but to launch the air
that we know must come next
[Applause]
and the stakes the stakes could not be
higher we cannot afford to miss the mark
or to miss this moment we must get this
right with Americans living under an
unaccountable president who will cut
taxes for corporations and then cut
Medicare Medicaid and Social Security
for the rest of us we must get this
right
[Applause]
when people of color fear for their own
place in their own country while infants
are torn from their parents at the
border we must get this right we're just
doing this Bernie won and when a
commander-in-chief pardons war criminals
and punishes war heroes while
systematically demolishing the
credibility of our country in the eyes
of the world we dare not risk four more
years of this presidency we must get
this right
[Applause]
[Applause]
now we the car clear-eyed about the
challenge before us and we must be
equally clear about the choice at hand
my competitors and I share the same
fundamental goals bringing balance to
our economy guaranteeing health care to
every American combating a climate
crisis and a rising tide of gun violence
but we do differ in what we believe it
will take to make that happen in this
election season we have been told by
some that you must either be for
revolution or you are for the status quo
but where does that leave the rest of us
this line got most Americans don't see
where they fit in that polarized vision
and we can't defeat the most divisive
president in modern American history by
tearing down anybody who doesn't agree
with us 100% of the time
[Applause]
Americans want the freedom to make
choices for themselves on healthcare or
on any other issue not to have
Washington decide for them and a
politics of my way or the highway is a
road to reelecting Donald Trump
vulnerable Americans do not have the
luxury of pursuing ideological purity
over an inclusive victory we also we
know this crowd didn't realize there was
the book that left them we also know
better than to try to defeat such a
disruptive president by relying on the
same Washington framework and mindset
after all
if today's Washington were serving
America well a guy like Donald Trump
would never have come within cheating
distance of the Oval Office in the first
place that's true
so to win and to govern we need to bring
new voices to our capital we need to get
Washington starting to work more like
our best run cities and towns rather
than the other way around and I know
that when you talk this way you might
get dismissed as a naive newcomer but a
fresh outlook is what makes new
beginnings possible it is how we build a
new majority and election after election
has shown us that putting forward a new
perspective is how Democrats win the
White House and we will win the White
House
if you are just joining us this has been
called for Bernie Sanders Bernie's lead
stretching too close to 5,000 votes with
83% reporting based on what is still
outstanding there appears to be no
mathematical real possibility for Pete
Budaj edge to take over we are hearing
from Peabody jej of course because this
is proportional allocation of Delegates
both Bernie and Peter ending up today
with basically the same number of
Delegates Perkins together not only in
the knowledge of what we must stand
against but in the confidence of knowing
what we are for this is the powerful
majority we are gathering together from
Davenport to Dover from Carson City to
Columbia it is a coalition of addition
not subtraction
it is a movement reaching into church
basements and barbershops into
universities and union halls carrying
the same values with us everywhere we go
we saw that Coalition Awakening we saw
it tonight
in cities and suburbs from the Seacoast
to those industrial towns too often left
behind
and together we are building a future
where there will be no such thing as an
uninsured American or an unaffordable
prescription this some candidate that's
what we can deliver with a plan most
Americans can get behind Medicare for
all who want it insuring care for every
American but trusting you to choose
whether you want it and when you want
[Applause]
together we will stop enabling corporate
greed and start raising wages empowering
workers and making good on the idea that
one job ought to be enough
[Applause]
together we will stop sending our young
people into the teeth of endless wars
and start recruiting every American to
Bernie Sanders you can see he is getting
ready to take these on the stage again
ready to hear supporters all right
Bernice reach now narrow victory same
number of Delegates but no doubt the
popular vote wins much like he had in
Iowa
[Applause]
thank you
thank you
thank you
any second now Tulsi is gonna take over
this entire thing I know you guys know
that
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
thank you
that was a joke just to be clear if
there's new viewers here thank you
Thank You New Hampshire
Thank You New Hampshire
this is Bernie's son right he follows me
on Twitter let me take this opportunity
to thank the people of the Hampshire for
a great victory tonight
and and let me thank the thousands of
volunteers in New Hampshire thank you
who knocked on doors in the rain and the
snow and the cold the reason that we won
tonight in New Hampshire we won last
week in Iowa popular vote that's true
it's because of the hard work of so many
volunteers
and let me say tonight that this victory
here is the beginning of the end for
Donald Trump right
are they saying Bernie Trump Bernie
beats from with with victories behind
thus popular vote in Iowa and the
victory iolite I love that we're going
to Nevada we're going to South Carolina
we're gonna win those states as well I
would prefer that he say Nevada and
South Carolina take the opportunity to
express my appreciation and respect for
all of the Democratic candidates
we ran against people to judge Amy
Klobuchar Elizabeth Warren Joe Biden who
else does he mention and what I can tell
you with absolute certainty and I know I
speak for every one of the Democratic
candidates is that no matter who is and
we certainly hope it's going to be us we
are going to unite together we are going
to unite together and defeat the most
dangerous president in the modern
history of this country
and the reason I believe we are going to
win Wow is that we have an unprecedented
grassroots movement from coast to coast
of millions of people the reason that we
are going to win is that we are putting
together an unprecedented
multi-generational multiracial political
movement and this is a movement from
coast to coast which is demanding that
we finally have an economy and a
government that works for all of us not
wealthy campaign contributors
[Applause]
and I want to thank all of those people
who have worked and contributed to our
campaign but make the point that in this
point in the campaign we are taking on
billionaires and we're taking on
candidates funded by billionaires
but we are gonna win because we have the
agenda that speaks to the needs of
working people throughout this country
healthcare is a human right not a
privilege
[Applause]
the wealthy and powerful will start
paying their fair share of taxes
we will make public colleges and
universities tuition-free and cancel all
student debt
[Applause]
[Music]
unlike Donald Trump we know that climate
change is very real and an existential
crisis for our planet we are prepared to
tell the fossil fuel industry that their
short-term profits are not more
important than the future of our planet
[Applause]
we are going to end a racist and broken
criminal justice system go on we are
going to pass comprehensive immigration
reform our gun safety policies will be
determined by the American people not
the NRA and under our administration it
will be women not the government who
control their own lives
[Applause]
now our campaign is not just about
beating Trump it is about transforming
this country it is about having the
courage to take on Wall Street the
insurance companies the drug companies
the fossil fuel industry the
military-industrial complex
[Applause]
so tonight I want to thank the people of
New Hampshire for this great victory
thank our volunteers and urge all
Americans to join our effort to
transform this country at Bernie Sanders
calm
so
it's on to the VAT up it's on to South
Carolina it's on to win the Democratic
nomination and together and together I
have no doubt that we will defeat Donald
Trump thank you all very much
Bernie Sanders with a victory speech in
New Hampshire Bernie Sanders coming out
ahead by several thousand votes will
likely come away with the same number of
Delegates as Pete Budaj edge considered
that Bernie Sanders has won the popular
vote now in 100 percent of this year's
primaries he won the popular vote in
Iowa as he says he won in New Hampshire
but will come away with fewer delegates
in the end most likely because he was
one delegate shy in Iowa and will end up
with the exact same as Pete Budaj edge
here in New Hampshire despite the win
that is right now about 44 97 44 97
something like that
yeah I believe that that is right so
that is where we are today upcoming we
still have let's see what PBS is doing
not clear upcoming we have let me look
at the calendar I believe that we have
next Saturday February 22nd are the
Nevada caucuses followed Saturday the
29th by the South Carolina primary is is
that right does any but can anybody
confirm that the the last two before
Super Tuesday are both Saturday
primaries if anybody can confirm that
22nd is correct for sure some people
saying and confirmed very wrote South
Carolina's on Tuesday I thought let's
confirm that South Carolina 2020 primary
is
the 29th Saturday so they are both
indeed Saturday an incredible day a much
smoother primary for sure than what we
saw in Iowa last Monday and we now go on
to I believe it is one more debate
somewhere around the I had that on my
calendar as well I want to make sure
everybody has the dates on Wednesday we
will have another debate and then satin
that's a week from tomorrow
and then Saturday the 26th second Nevada
will vote so quite an evening that is
going to conclude our coverage and I
look forward to seeing everybody back
for our New Hampshire post game analysis
on tomorrow's broadcast show and the
youtube channel of course
thank you for joining